e
okay it's 10: a.m. so we're going to get
going uh representative quaale would you
okay um we're going to open up the
public hearing for the house election
law committee uh just a quick kind of
advice uh advice to the committee
members today is going to be the first
day of what I call the the uh session of
grind so we have if we were to only meet
on Tuesdays from now on we would have to
he hear over 18 over 18 bills every
Tuesday um so couple things there's
going to be one or two days we're going
to have to come in not on a Tuesday um
and number two is what you're going to
see today where we're moving people
along we're moving bills along quickly
that is going to be our normal um
there's just no other way to do it so I
understand the com concerns against that
um we have 75 bills in our possession
currently there could be more coming
through vacation not through vacation
but people vacating bills um
so just be aware I understand that not
everybody's going to like when I'm
imposing the time limits and moving
people
along got to talk to your colleagues
about not filing 75 bills um and then we
can go back to the way it was but this
is what it's going to be like so uh
we're going to have probably some
Growing Pains today as we move through
11 bills which is by the way not enough
um but that's how it's going to be so
anyways we're going to start it off uh
going to open up the public hearing for
House Bill 107 relative to political
advertising printed in newspaper
periodicals or Billboards uh
representative Perez is recognized for
introduction of the Bill thank you
thanks for hearing my bill uh this is
just a cleanup I'll be two minutes
actually this is to add what was taken
out of a bill last year um and what it
is is that the political adverti printed
in newspapers periodicals Billboards
don't need to be marked at the beginning
at the end it really shouldn't be the
responsibility of outlets to be
responsible for what um candidates are
putting on and this came up uh for those
of you who were not here last year came
up because there was a um a court case
against a small business a small um
paper owner in londondary and um because
she didn't write political advertisement
above some um political advertisements I
mean if it said Christine Perez for you
know State Rep obviously it was but she
was taken to court and she was find for
it so any and I'm willing to take
questions are questions from the
committee now SE and I feel your pain we
had 65 people speak at a hearing
yesterday I hear you um okay thank you
representative Perez uh I think only
have one pink card um so I've got oh
it's the name I'm going buter Kaye you
don't I'm G to
try
esto
of the house election law committee um
for the record my name is Kaye of stadio
I'm a Durham voter and public policy
fellow with open democracy we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit representing
36,000 voters across the state and I'm
submitting testimony today in opposition
to HB 107 relative to political
advertising printed in newspapers
periodicals and billboards the existing
statute RSA
6646 which requires political
advertisements to be labeled as such in
print is rooted in common sense HB 107
would effectively delete this language
from current election law allowing for
the unintentional perpetuation of
political
misinformation electoral transparency is
an integral component of a healthy
democracy and I see no reason to
Backside by withholding potentially
influential information from voters
voters should have the right to to know
who is buying influence through ads the
primary goal of political advertising is
not to inform the public in a neutral
manner but to gain more votes and
naturally this can lead to the
unfortunate inclusion of hyperbolic
language and falsehoods in otherwise
well intentioned
advertisements and there is no federal
or state penalty on the books for lying
in paid political advertisement as of
now which is why holding candidates and
committees accountable through mandatory
disclosure is so important clear PR
ident has also been said regarding the
matter Miss Deborah Paul as mentioned
before publisher of the linary times was
found guilty of five misdemeanor charges
and fin in 2023 for failing to Mark
political advertisements as such despite
receiving several warnings in the Years
leading up to this the consequences for
omitting this crucial information are
clear and should not be dismissed on a
whim please consider voting HB 107
expedient to legislate striking this
legislation would be detrimental to the
Integrity of our campaign processes and
the already fragile system of media
messaging that our society relies so
heavily on thank you will you be taking
questions uh yes are there questions
from the
committee okay oh yes representative
C thank you for Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh shouldn't it
be the hus be on the person buying the
ad rather than the
publisher um I would say that the media
has a duty to just disclose any
information that they
have yeah further
questions seeing none thank you um I
don't have any more pink cards
representative Gaz offski
sheet uh online we had three in support
and uh signing up in person and not
speaking was one against so with that
saying no one else wishing to speak uh
we are going to close the public hearing
on House Bill 107 and stand in recess
until 1020 for the purpose of
introduction of House Bill 336 uh you've
got 14 minutes so um representative
Wilhelm your
um your R your deput your Deputy ranking
m is not here um but uh the Republicans
are going to C us real fast just to chat
so if you want to do so the same I might
recommend it get on the same page
opportunity to talk um but we'll see you
had
SP
round
my
e
you
w
people
don't
okay we're g to we're going to reconvene
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 336 relative to the placement
of political advertisements on public
rways
um representative Judy Aaron you are
introduction thank you so much Mr chair
and members of the committee the
election law committee for the record my
name is representative Judy Aon and I
represent the towns of aworth Goan Lang
lster and Washington which is Sullivan
County District
4 I'm introducing this bill to you today
HP 336 relative to the placement of
political advertisements on public right
of ways I'm here to help clarify the law
after an incident that happened in
Claremont this past election cycle we
had an incident where candidate sinage
was placed on the Claremont green one
morning members of Black lives matters
began to illegally remove signs that
were placed on the green and so the
incident along with video footage was
reported to the New Hampshire Attorney
General's office the attorney en's
office then wrote a letter to the city
manager citing RSA 664 colon 17 saying
that and and I I um given you a packet
with the letter from the attorney
general to Claremont as well as the
letter from Claremont back to uh the
Attorney General's office and so the
Attorney General's office wrote a letter
saying that the political signs are
forbidden on public property and that
they their office requested that all
political signs be removed from public
property
immediately this request was
communicated to all candidates and
everyone scurried around removing their
signage uh to to take every in any place
that was a public uh right away uh the
candidates were instructed that they had
to come and pick up their
signs in the meantime the city's
manager's attorney the city manager's
attorney uh or the city's attorney wrote
back back to the New Hampshire attorney
general with a different interpretation
of the statute plus identifying what
they believed was an inconsistency in
the
statute they wrote uh quote lastly if
you consider the overall statutory
scheme and language of the entirety of
this legislative act you will have to
arrive at the same logical conclusion as
to the meaning of said statute another
sentence in this law sets forth quote no
person shall remove deface or knowingly
destroy any political advertising which
is placed on or a fixed to public
property or any private property except
for removal by the owner of the property
persons authorized by the owner of the
property or a law enforcement officer
removing improper advertising end quote
that's in the
law they continued and they said if your
interpretation of RSA 664 colon 17 were
correct then why would the legislature
have to insert language prohibiting
removal of said political advertising by
non authorized individuals on public
property if such initial action the
placement of the political advertising
was illegal in the first
place anyway after their F their back
and forth exchange the City of Claremont
granted permission for political signage
to be able to be placed on their public
land and all candidates were informed
that they could again put their signs
back for that couple of weeks it was a
very confusing and crazy time people
were wondering whether they could put
signs up not put signs up where they can
put them where they couldn't put them
and so forth and because there seems to
be so much confusion over that I brought
this bill forward to try and clear up
the statute and make it so that local
municipalities can grant permission for
signage to be placed on public land and
publicly owned rights of way and I look
forward to your conversation on this
issue and would be happy to answer any
questions and as I said I've also
provided the letters that were written
matter um other questions from the
committee yes representative Newsome
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question um property rights
in New Hampshire often go to the center
line of the road for the landowner and
um the right of way then goes out from
that Center so there is an overlapping
area where it is in the right of way
owned controlled by the town for a road
and owned by the property owner with
this language saying or by consent could
the town give permission to put signs in
the right of way which is otherwise
private property thank you I would not I
don't believe so because uh no it we
also say here no political advertising
shall be placed on private property
without the owner's
consent so thank you have both you would
need both uh consent from the local
municipality as well as a private land
owner if there was uh any kind of
overlap I'm sorry a followup yes follow
I'm sorry did you say you would need
both or just one just the property owner
well from with the property owner okay
perfect thank you
yeah further questions me representative
P Brian you thank you Mr chairman so I'm
a little unclear on what happened
exactly in Claremont that um
that made you want to file this
legislation was and I know every
Community is different with the
different Traditions that they have for
where people campaigning put signs so
was it the case that in Claremont there
was a public area like a park or a a
their green yeah it was their public
Green Town Center the town green
and historically people have put signs
there corre people from all different
political sides signs there and the town
allowed it yes and then some some sign
was there and BLM opposed it but could
they have put their own signs there as
well if they wanted to they could have
put their own signs up but they were
illegally Mo removing you're not
supposed to touch anybody else's signage
once it's erected wherever it is and um
they were REM physically removing the
signs there was someone taking video of
it and everything and reported that
incident to the Attorney General's
office in New Hampshire and the Attorney
General then wrote back this letter to
the City of Claremont saying well you're
not supposed to have anything on your
public land anyway so we want you to
remove them because you're breaking the
law and they wrote back and they said
well no because we're giving permission
essentially to put those signs up so I I
don't know if they had heard gotten a
respon resp back from uh the Attorney
General's office but they Grant the City
of Claremont granted permission for
people to put their signs back
up further questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you
representative Aaron thank you so much I
appreciate your time next up is
representative
dry welcome to election
law thank you Mr chairman thank you for
hearing uh this bill my for the record
my name is representative Margaret dry I
represent Sullivan County district 7 and
bill I just want to add a a piece of
experience as an EMT and a rescue
Personnel um for driving around when
it's political season uh in our town
unfortunately uh it gets surrounded by
rumor whether or not political signs are
allowed to be placed on the right away
or certain sections of town and
unfortunately people take advantage of
that and put things around stop signs
yield signs and places where it
distracts drivers because it is um it
draws attention to this area below the
sign and not the stop sign especially on
country country roads where it's sharp
corners and uh and often blind driveways
um I like this because it it makes it
more um of the onus on the asking for
Poli iCal
subdivision uh permission uh I just hope
that political subdivisions understand
that it they need to be very specific um
because people interpret uh what they
mean by public land as a lot of
different things in a rural area and I
just wanted to bring up that point as
we're working on it I know it says you
can't interrup the safe flow of traffic
but a sign near a stop sign doesn't
necessarily interrupt the flow of
traffic but it does interrupt the safety
thank you will we taking questions from
the
committee we have to say yes or no oh
yes okay are there questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you thank you very much um next up is
Sarah Burke
Association good morning my name is
Sarah Burke Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the nhma
supports this bill this bill clarifies
the law currently where political
advertising can be posted and the
consent that must be sought should it be
on public property um and or private uh
private property the language contained
in this bill is consistent with property
ownership and Highway Law related to
rights of way I'll take
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you you're
welcome um I don't have any more pink
cards representative gski working on did
I get it right all right um can you pass
me that blue sheet and online we
had six in support three opposed is
there anyone else wishing to speak on
this bill seeing none we'll get this
up okay all
right spoke
spoke one spoke uh okay and sign up on
the blue sheet who did not speak uh one
in support one against with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
336 um and we will stand in recess until
10:40 for the purpose of introduction
for uh similar subject requiring HP 423
requiring the consent of property owners
for the placement of political
advertisements on public property AB
budding their land all right see you
10:40
e
good morning it's 20 of 11 and and at
the request of the chair I as Vice chair
will be opening the public hearing am
opening the public hearing for HP
423 and I recognize representative wher
wer Wier excuse me thank you to uh
testify for the Bill thank you uh
representative Kena Rockingham
14 uh my 19th term in the house for the
last 30 years I believe that RSA 66417
gave me as the butter the right to
control who placed political advertising
on the corner lot where I live I would
take the sign of a candidate whom I did
not support lat on the lay it on the
ground place a copy of RSA 66417
attached to it with a note that I was a
butter and this sign does not have my
permission sometimes it took more than
one notice to cause the sign to be taken
away but generally I had cooperation and
the signs were removed the last election
I had one candidate who was a had a very
aggressive campaign attacking the
candidate whom I support it I had to
remove her sign three times one of her
workers came to my house to argue that I
had no right to do that her campaign her
campaign manager made a fuss and since
he had earlier worked with the attorney
general he got that office to send me a
cease and assist order I passed out
about a dozen copies of that half a
dozen copies of that I didn't make
enough for everybody the CE and deist
order made no sense it referred to the
abing highway as being purchased by the
state under fee simple and gave the
impression that the law only applied to
a Butters who owned the land over which
the road passed that would be a class
six Road and would have so little
traffic on it that it would not attract
any political advertising I've changed
the wording of
66417 to make it clear that the butter
has the right to object to political
advertising the right to remove it from
display by placing it flat place a copy
of this irsa on it with the Butter's
name and address I hope that the
committee agrees with my reasoning and
takes the opportunity to make this law
clear and approve the action by by an
objecting a
butter excuse me which otherwise is
lacking the law says you have to have
the but's permission but it doesn't say
what you do if you don't have it so I'm
trying to put the language in there to
make it clear you don't just slash it or
or tear it up you have to treat it with
respect lay it flat so it's not on
display and then put this note on it
which is what I've been doing for 30
years and most people respect it until
this person made a fuss and she lost
anyway but anyway I'm trying to make it
clear that if if the loss said if it's
on state right away with without the
objection of the abutter that I wanted
to make the language clear because
obviously this attorney general did not
understand it so I hope you can support
it and and improve the law by and this
law gets amended every few years anyway
as you've seen so
That's My Hope thank you I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you
representative are there any questions
from the
committee representative Mirad thank you
Mr Vice chair
um looking at the proposed legislation
it looks like it makes two changes one
is it has this process for what to do
when there's something there um which
makes which I appreciate um and another
thing is it changes the language
from um owner of the land over which the
ride of way passes to property owner
who's the closest to butter and and and
thinking about that change it it gave me
just a little bit of caution because I'm
thinking about for instance an
intersection in Newport where a couple
State highways intersect and there's a
state park there and the nearest to
butter is actually quite a way away from
the intersection but now the near under
this language the nearest to butter
would have the ability to come in and
and monitor the signage even though
their property is not actually very
close to that intersection they they're
the closest to butter um and so I wonder
could we keep the old language that says
over which the RightWay passes well if
we have an attorney general who assumes
that's a class six
Highway and goes on about the fee simple
oh no we bought that so you don't have
any
rights nobody knows who who bought the
road that goes by their property you
don't know whether it's fee simp simp Le
class 5 class you know I I'm on a class
so one of the I'm on this corner class
one and class two where class two is
going to a state park and class one is a
major highway okay I wouldn't have any
right according to this attorney general
because they bought it under fee simple
I'm trying to straighten him out it's
either it's it's got to fit in one of
these classes and if if it claims the
right away over
which the road passes the the right away
over over your property that's a class
six Road well you own if it's abandoned
you own to the middle of the road so in
effect you have some ownership of that
road if it's discontinued as a RightWay
that's the misunderstanding that that
I'm trying to do away with which
obviously this attorney general says oh
no we own this fee simple and only it
only applies to the Landover right and I
said you know at one point the property
I bought that Highway had been widened
and had been taken from the property
that I bought so is that the owner of
the land over which the RightWay passes
so no well no no we own it on a fee
simple you don't seem to understand why
would I put advertising on a class six
Highway nobody goes down it but that's
his interpretation so I want to make it
clear now in this case of the so here's
here's the land it comes across like
this then there's a couple of
islands I don't have anything to do with
the islands I figure so so it's the same
thing I'm the nearest to butter to this
corner but if if there's something
interven in intervening in the way that
is public stuff then you're not quite
the nearest to butter um as you say
there's a there's a park and those other
things I'd have to look at the
intersection to give you a real good
answer but I don't think the nearest to
butter if you're 200 feet away and you
you can't even see it but the idea is
everybody knows who I am who I support
if somebody that's I support sticks a
sign in front of my property and
somebody says I voted for him because
you had a sign there that wasn't who I
was support but I couldn't remove the
sign because I had a cease and assist
that doesn't seem right if it if the
first written law said you needed
permission of the person of whose
property the right away passes and so if
it's going to be misinterpreted by an
attorney general I wanted to make it a
little clearer so I put in the nearest
the butter I hope it doesn't
that situation is rare enough that
somebody says no you weren't the nearest
to butter because all this public
property was here in the in the interim
which wasn't known by you and it wasn't
part of the RightWay so that was my
interpretation do you see my point I do
thank you thank
committee okay representative
uh thank you Vice chair and thank you
for taking my question just um I'm just
curious
uh about the mechanism for remedying
when you find these signs uh
objectionable signs placed
um if if you were found removing them do
you you know is it would an alternate
possibility to contact authorities to
ask them to remove it rather than have
you as the abutter removing them and and
kind of running the risk of being
misinterpreted or misconstrued as uh
removing signs improperly when I when I
go to remove the sign I have a copy of
664 in my hand that I'm going to tape to
the sign if anybody comes say sayy
you're illegal say read the law here I
am I wrote my name and address on here I
can show you my ID I'm the guy that's
written the note I'm leaving it on the
sign otherwise it might take two weeks
before the authorities got there to
remove it or it it wouldn't happen
immediately but I've had signs that
somebody complained about blocking their
view they were gone pretty quick but you
know I'm not sure if I called up and
said I don't like so and so
sign whether they whether they'd get to
it right away and say yeah yeah we'll
get to it I just figure that you know
especially if it's the same person I've
sent the note to they just ignore it and
put the sign up again I'm going to take
it down again the town might not be that
quick
so but I think it we do need to describe
in the law what you can do if you
object representative Nome thank you
very much thanks for taking my question
looking at
66417 which is the statute that you
cited as giving you permission to take
down these signs it says no political
advertising shall be placed or on or
affixed to any public property including
Highway rights of or private property
without the owner's
consent does this your bill expand that
to then a butter so if that right of way
is across my land you as a butter would
now have control over what signs I put
up it seems to be these two the bill and
the existing statute are in Conflict how
do you feel so where is your property
and where is where am I the nearest the
butter well I'm just looking at the
statute that requires the
permission from the owner and not it
66417 so if you were renting a property
and you're well known in a certain party
and somebody else stuck signs in front
of you and they said you can't have no
right to remove it but I'm saying if all
of a sudden people say what did you
change your party why are you supporting
him or her and you know this way it's
clear if you're if it's sitting in front
of where you
live then you should have the right to
say I don't want that sign
there so I'm I think that's what the
original Law intended and the original
Law assumed that everybody who lived in
house that they owned rather than rented
or or whatever but it it seemed to work
for years until these people start
dealing with the attorney generals that
don't know the difference between a
class five and a class six
road so and especially
yes go ahead uh what exactly is the
difference statutorily or whatever with
the five and six because I thought that
the default rule in New Hampshire is
that the landowner owns to the center of
the road not just on class six it
certainly happens when a class six road
is thrown up that then the two abutters
along that right of way own to the
center line but they own that either way
even if it's not given up in many roads
that is the default in the state I that
was my impression at least we may
disagree that's fine though the class
one
road not
only does it take all the pavement but
it has the shoulders and the drainage
ditches and all that and it may go
anywhere from 35 to 40 ft and so it
turns out that most of us mowing the
grass we're mowing the state's property
and that's why we put a law in there
with an exception let's say you mowed
your neighbor's grass for for 20 years
you could claim it was yours you can't
do that with the state right away we put
in a specific thing most people don't
know where the state owns to and every
once in a while when I look at a map and
go to the the registry of deeds it
varies it's what was available for them
to take in some cases it goes 20 feet
into what you think is your
property and that's what they bought
because that was what available when
they bought when they put the road in
and that's what they decided to take and
sometimes because of drainage ditches
and and and culs and things they took a
little more in some places so very few
of us know exactly where the edge of the
state's property on the road and our own
is so I just want to make it clear since
they could put something right almost
next to my steps and say oh I just
looked it up in the county they actually
own right up to your
steps i' say wow I hadn't gone and
looked at that but that's that's the way
some of the properties are when I
researched them I was on the planning
board for years and we look at these
things and it would vary and sometimes
they took so much land they'd be willing
to sell it and one of my neighbors they
they took a piece of property that would
have allowed him to expand his business
and
I called up the real estate people and
they were very slow in getting back to
us and saying we haven't decided yet but
he's been trying for years to get this
piece of property because they took a
whole house
slot they were moving the road apart
expanding the highway this is again on
125 and it came so close to the person's
property they didn't want to keep the
house anymore so I think it came right
into the house so they said all right we
got to take the whole thing so now they
got that house was fairly close to the
to the front of the property once they
took the house it was another 200 ft
behind it that they had to take so
here's the butter wants to buy that
piece to enlarge his business and still
safe far enough away from the highway so
you don't never you never know exactly
how wide that right away is that they
took it's my point I've discovered that
from years of being on the planning
you uh representative
C thank you for taking my question um
you'd mentioned U tenants and I just got
to wondering what happens if the tenant
and the building owner don't
agree I think the building owner would
have the right to say I don't want this
on my property it does it's not included
in your
lease so you know but I've seen it
ways by representative
toner thank you um I just had a question
so like I'm just trying to play this
through my mind um so in your situation
for
Simplicity is it a scenario where
basically you have whatever Main Highway
going and you're say your property lines
are perpendicular for Simplicity to that
Highway and obviously they can own 50
feet 100 feet off the center line up
into your property is that the scenario
that's playing out here that basically
someone put a
sign right up next to the edge of the
highway and it happens to be in between
more or less the the property lines of
your piece of property yeah my my
property runs about a thousand feet
along 125 so I sometimes use that as I
am the abutter m and then I my house
faces on another road that goes into 125
that's where I live and then it goes
around the corner but my property goes
AB buts both Highway the highway and my
the road I use as my address so I own
the corner lot which I say gives me
control of the corner and as it is I AB
but 125 as I say for 1,000 ft so I
assume that I could say anywhere along
there I object to
this that's that's what I'm saying so it
would in my mind I'm the nearest to
butter so but here's this little islands
that go like this I don't try to claim
control over them because they're
between the road this road and that road
so lots of things get put on those
islands that I object to but I don't
figure I have the the right the same as
I do or I'm in the butter thank
you further questions from the
committee uh representative Harvey
bullier thank you Mr chair um just a
quick question uh I thank you for
bringing up this bill because I've often
wondered about this sort of piece of law
but assuming I'm thinking of samton
Center where there's an island very
popular for sticking signs in and I
don't assume you can see all the way
over but assuming there's an abutter
there's two roads sort of intersecting
and there's an AB butter on either side
they have differing political opinions I
know how do how would that work out
would you say is where they're kind of
equidistant they they're they don't AB
but that
diamond they on their side of the road
they're an abutter but the diamond yeah
nope that's just Frontage then it's
Frontage okay two L on the inside
excuse me yeah one person at a time
speaking and I would like to make a note
that if we could stick to the specifics
of the bill with regard to our questions
I think that would be more helpful thank
you now I want to make it clear that not
only the the rights of way the state's
rights of way that AB but your property
but also the method you have to do if
you object because it the present law
doesn't give you any any way to deal
with
it that's the point I want to make I
might you might end up combining this
law and the previous law however you
want them do it in the committee but I
hope you you keep both the the rights of
the abutter and the rights and the
method to deal with something you object
to otherwise it's not in the
law thank you are there any other
questions from the committee yes
directed more towards the specifics of
this particular
Bill uh thank you very much
attention I be no further oh I see a red
card coming indicating someone else
testify
okay um
[Music]
oh next thank you I didn't read it thank
you all right see no no further red
cards indicating someone wishes to
testify on this
bill I will call the meeting to a close
adjourn
it at
10:59 a.m. just in time for the next
yes I have the blue sheet I have see two
people wanted to State their views
without testifying one was in favor of
it being 11: a.m. exactly I will open
okay the acting chair recognizes the
prime sponsor representative JD Bernardi
thank you for coming to testify
today thank you acting chair and the
election committee uh I am
representative JD Bernardi Rockingham 36
Hampton Falls Kensington Southampton
Newton and plastow I'm here to introduce
HB
448 which establishes a committee to
study violations found in the 5 April
2023 ballot law commission I have given
you four of the summary books of that
commission um and if more are needed we
can get those as well as uh um
representative brandano behind me will
show you the Full Compilation of all the
violations in a larger text uh that may
be
useful so what is this all about uh this
was
uh Senate District 242
22 El election uh was
investigated by 700 with 700 hours of
lay volunteer
work uh to basically document the
problems that they found with various
election law
violations uh in that
election their um the results of their
work was presented to the B law
commission by attorney McDonald and
after reviewing over 100 documented
violations uh in in many areas uh they
referred the issue to the attorney
general uh now what kind of issues are
we talking about talking about absentee
ballot controls and Rec Rec uh
reconciliation talking about the
counting machine's qualification and
operations we're talking about multiple
chain of custody issues with
inappropriately sealed boxes missing
signatures inaccurate vote counts things
in the wrong boxes that are totally
mislabeled um so over aund and over a
hundred violations were
noted uh and
including over approximately
2400 moved voters people who had moved
out of the towns still on the
registration
lists so uh and lastly missing the
required continuity operation plan which
every town is supposed to have for when
things go south during your election
process so all these violations were
heard and acknowledged by the ballot law
commission and they did not believe that
they had the authority to take any
action on them but they believe they
were they were legitimate violations so
so so they turned them over to the
attorney
general the Attorney General did not
pursue these in any kind of Court
proceeding I asked the Attorney General
why and it's very simple New Hampshire
election laws do not have attached
penalties so we say put all the put all
the ballots in a box seal it with tamper
evident tape and if the box shows up
tamper evident tape's clearly been uh
dislodged the signatures across that are
are missing um the boxes are still
accepted in a Recon procedure even
though there you have no idea if they've
been opened or tampered with and
evidence shows that so that's a just one
of many many many uh uh violations that
we've seen here that that that they
reported and are they're summarized in
those smaller books uh and a and a
larger book lists every single violation
that
occurred so you ask why do I raise this
issue it's because I've spoken to many
members of the legislature on Election
Committee in in the past election law in
the past and they say well the number of
violations we have are minor they're not
that many they're infrequent we don't
need to deal with
that I think this particular episode
demonstrates the falsity of that
assertion we have many many of these
kinds of problems and it calls out and
and the documentation submitted to the
ballot law commission basically asks
that three issues be addressed
additional training for the people in
the process of uh managing our
elections further auditing of the
process and finally attaching
appropriate penalties to the violations
that that are observed so when
violations occur and they can be
referred to the attorney general or the
Secretary of State whatever office you
believe is appropriate for uh for
addressing them they can take
appropriate
action what we have here is a A system
that continually causes concern by
individuals in the public
saying is my vote really being counted
when I see all these violations is my
vote being tampered with when I see all
these violations and nothing
happens so this committee I I would
actually prefer you look at all of
election law and deal with training
auditing and uh penalties but in order
to put a stake in the ground that this
is real I took this massive number of
violations seen by the bout law
commission validated by the bout law
commission that these are real this is
not fantasy um and and present that to
you as a as a grounds for moving forward
and happy to take any
questions okay thank you do we have any
committee uh representative
Ward I'm sorry representative wood
that's fine thank you okay well did I
jump ahead of you okay thank you for
taking my question um it seems to me
that bring you're bringing this forward
to just uh continue the process of
someone looking into this is that true
or have we found uh any other problems
to to why can I ask you why you bringing
this forward at this point I I bring It
Forward because it it's clear
documentation of the kinds of problems
that we've seen and I asked for a
committee to study it to not you you
can't undo what has been done but put
together procedures that will limit
these kinds of problems in the future
and that that boils down to training of
the people that are conducting the
elections auditing to make sure that you
really are implementing those training
procedures and people are following the
law as written and thirdly penalties
that ascribed to the violations so that
they're just not
ignored and and that's the problem that
we have we have you know you can you can
look at these violations and say oh this
is this is just a little minor thing but
if this is repetitive and ubiquitous
over and over and over again we see
these problems you you have an
electorate that's saying I don't trust
the process and we do not want to be
there so I want the committee to to to
the committee to appro pass this uh Bill
and establish a committee that will make
recommendations to our our uh election
law to change it to to address those
three
things okay thank
you further
questions representative
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question when you started
out your testimony you spoke of 700
hours of lay volunteer work yes you
characterize was that a group yes there
were there were several individuals
involved in the uh uh election area of
District
24 from the different towns in in that
area and they collectively looked at
what happened in their respective towns
uh and and um scoured through you know
what happened during that election and
compiled their
observations which were then brought
before the bout law
commission so not an organized group
it's not a defined entity no it was it
was these are uh willing citizens
looking at what's going on and and
concerned with the election process
particularly in that particular election
thank you further questions uh
representative prome O'Brien I have a
lot of questions I'm trying to organize
them could you remind us who the
candidates were and 2022 I did look up
some uh information about that district
and I see that as pretty evenly split
Republican Democrat demographically but
who are those candidates that year in
2022 for Senate that was Lugar julo as a
republican candidate and uh Al Chiller
as the uh Democratic
candidate uh the district is uh tends to
be uh more it's not evenly split it's
it's more of a democratic District
because of the town of exitor which is
very strongly Democratic okay you should
like a followup yes I I have a
followup I'm just thinking back to
some difficulties that I also
experienced in my own Community
regarding similar issues and a Senate
District is of course much different
you've got many communities that you're
working with did people in those
communities come forward and
make um reports about specific election
law violations within their Community to
the Secretary of State and the Attorney
General's office in an effort to um to
fix that problem and that's what I
recall having been done in my own
Community there were reports to the
secret State office by the members of
individual communities but then the work
was done to consolidate every everything
that happened in all the communities
involved in District
24 to create this Consolidated list of
you know we have these problems here and
those problems there and let's put it
all on one one big report and let's
bring this to the ballot law commission
and that went to the attorney general I
do not know if any
individuals uh went directly from their
Community to the AG's office I don't I
don't think that happened but it may
have uh represent uh excuse me Al
brandano behind me uh could probably
question representative wood thank thank
you Mr chair um regarding the action of
the commission what was their action I I
know you mentioned I just want to make
sure I'm clear what was their action
what was their recommendation out of
this their recommendation was that these
were
legitimate findings and that they
couldn't take action on them so they
referred because they they considered
them violations of the law they referred
them to the attorney general for his
action I thank you that was very clear
thank
you representative
Mirad thank you um I wonder if you could
help me with the phrase the April 25th
2023 ballot law commission and what that
refers to when I look at the ballot law
commission page on the Secretary of
State's website I see meetings that were
held on April 5th and 2023 and a meeting
that's held on May 25th 2023 but not a
meeting that was held on April 25th 2023
no it's a April 5th is the right did I
say 25th if I did April 25th Mr chair
that uh that's what it says in the title
of the bill April 25th that's that's a
typo it's the 5th of
April in fact the the document should
say that that you have okay thank you
followup may I ask whether the minutes
of the April fifth meeting will have a a
discussion of these violations certainly
yes okay uh representative
warry thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent for taking my question just
want to clarify you've mentioned uh the
three aspects I I saw the ballot law
commission presentation and I'm familiar
with it so thank you uh for bringing
that up uh the you've mentioned training
auditing and penalties however the scope
of Duties on lines 10 and 11 seem to
refer specifically to the Penalty aspect
um so is is it your desire to have both
penalties if you look at the
recommendation in the actual uh
documentation presented to the bout law
commission those are the three areas
that they call out I agree with them
when the when this bill was written it
was just it focused in on the penalties
because if you if you don't have a
penalty for the for for breaking the
rules you're never going to get anywhere
it's the only way you're going to get
attention of people who don't follow the
rules now if you want to get better
compliance you're going to train an
audit as well that's only
logical but but
ultimately the you're you're not going
penalty further questions from the
committee representative Gilmore thank
you do you have a listed these
violations yes they they're they're in a
a larger
uh book with all I think there's 121
total and uh Al brandano behind me has
has that book does he have he's
gonna that if if the committee wants to
move forward with this so we can make
copies of that and and have that
available yes thank
you further questions from the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much representative
Bernardi thank
you I'm going to call Secretary of State
secretary thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm David
scandin Secretary of State and I'd like
to provide some information just to put
this issue in perspective uh for the
committee first of all what's going
around the room are the minutes from the
bow law commission meeting where they
took this issue up and then the second
document is the response from the
attorney from the Attorney General's
office uh after receiving the uh the
Commission in terms of elections in New
Hampshire the process that has developed
over
over a couple centuries is both a
blessing and a curse it's a blessing
because uh the elections are run by We
the People citizens from every one of
your communities are elected by their
neighbors friends family members uh and
general community members to do these
jobs um that are pretty important and
hopefully they get elected to do those
jobs based on their
integrity uh and and the ability in the
that the process itself has many checks
and balances in it so that after the
election is over if there's a close race
or even a not so close race in the case
of the Senate uh District 24 recount
where the the uh the difference between
winning and losing was over 3,000 votes
There's an opportunity for a recount
where the ballots can be reviewed and
challenged further um and if there are
ballots that have been challenged for
further appeal that might make the
difference in the outcome of the
election uh that issue can be taken to
the bout law commission who will make an
additional ruling on whether the intent
of the voter on those ballots was
accurately recorded or not and then
ultimately issues can be taken to our
state court system for you know
because the citizens run the elections
in this state they are not perfect and
they never will be perfect even though
that's what we strive for there's just a
human element of this that is is
prevalent you know I would I would
compare it to a classroom where you know
you have some students that are going to
get all A's all the time you know you
don't have to worry about mistakes on
their you know on their tests uh and
then you proba have the larger bulk of
students that are going to be in the B
C+ range where they're not perfect all
the time but you know they know enough
to get the job done and then they going
to be people in the class that simply
are going to fail and the election
process that we have really is no
different because of collectively you
know we're we're dealing with a
representation of society as a whole and
we don't have all a students that are
running our elections uh that are going
to be perfect every time and I think the
report that you have seen is is
expecting that and um I don't think that
that is particularly realistic now we do
have laws on the books and the laws have
to be followed and to help the local
election officials do their jobs as
accurately and efficiently as possible
uh we do a significant amount of
training and that training process is
growing all the time um I just when I uh
when I first started working in the
Secretary of State's office it was in
the year 2002 so I've been at this for
quite some time and I can tell you that
when I started working in the
office and this is part of putting this
whole thing in
perspective there was nothing uniform
about the processes that were taking
place in polling places around the St
State this was the set of statutes that
we had in the 1998 99 session and
compared to the statutes that we have
today and you can see this the today's
book is about twice the size of the book
25 years
ago this was the election procedure
manual in
1989 this is the election procedure
manual today
and when I went around to polling places
uh when I was first serving as deputy
secretary of state we would walk in
and the processes that were taking place
were clearly not consistent with what
the statutes uh required that they be
and when we would inquire with the local
election officials about how that
process is working they said well we
never looked at the law that's just the
way we've always done it and and so um
we've come a long way in 25 years uh
during that time there was the passage
of the help America vote act it required
that we have a centralized Statewide
voter database uh which we just replaced
now with a brand new system but up until
we created that in around
every every municipality in New
Hampshire maintain their checklist in
their own way
and that ranged from really nice
spreadsheets in the major cities in New
Hampshire to hand recorded checklists in
the small towns like orange where after
every election they would hand write out
a brand new checklist and that's how
they were maintained so you know we've
Consolidated uh we had to aggregated all
of that information all of that data we
had to put it in a uniform format get it
into the database so it could be
properly
used the
the training that we put on now as I
mentioned before is very extensive we do
it both in person uh and online and
there are dozens of opportunities every
year for local election officials to get
trained on the proper procedures and uh
uh processes that should take place in a
polling place and we are seeing
Improvement but you that's going to be
an ongoing job up we're talking about
probably close to 3,000 election
officials that are you know assign these
duties not volunteers that help on the
election day but actual officials that
are involved in this process and as you
can imagine there was constant turnover
uh in those numbers uh after every local
election and so the training is ongoing
and it is always from
scratch two more uh
um more involved uh processes in the
polling place and so along with that
there are varying degrees of ability
brand new people that have no idea about
the total text that is in this document
versus some longers that have been
around a while and they know how to do
things uh properly so you know I am uh I
I am sensitive to the issues that have
been raised I don't think that that they
raised to the level of of the Integrity
of the election itself being jeopardized
I think if the people on my staff at a
recount were visiting polling places
noticed ballot boxes or things that were
in a condition where they needed to be
investigated uh we would do that without
hesitation but I think for the most part
the election officials uh that we have
in New Hampshire are dedicated ated uh
they want to do a good job I think for
the most part they do an excellent job
and I would hate to see anything uh
occur in the form of legislation that is
punitive and this study committee is
designed to look at being punitive when
the mistakes that are made are uh
technical clerical and certainly not
intentional so with that I would be
happy to answer questions the committee
might have thank you Mr secretary do we
have questions from the committee
bearing in mind we're now a bit over
schedule and if if we
could I can't enforce this but if you
could try to keep the questions to the
subject of the
legislation uh as discussed so
far okay thank you representative wood
thank you for T taking my question so it
seems to me that the concern I don't
want to put words to you out sorry what
is your concern with this bill which
side are you on I I I didn't get that
from your explanation if you could help
concern is I think it's good to be
skeptical of the processes that we have
and it's good to have oversight and and
I've always said that the process needs
to be completely transparent we as
transparent as it can possibly be and I
think the intent of this bill is
certainly in line with that what what I
would hate to see however
is it in the bill if you look at it
there's language to look at
uh uh it was punitive you know to look
at you know what the remedy would be for
penalties um that would be applied and
and I don't think that that if we do
that we're going to discourage people
from stepping forward to perform these
roles because they're going to be
concerned that if they make a technical
error or just a simple mistake um that
they may be penalized for it uh and
guilty of a violation of Law and um I
think the the important thing is to
continue with
education and and we're doing that um
you know certainly that requires
resources and if it's the Judgment of
this Committee in the legislature that
we need to do more then I think we need
to be prepared to pay for it and um uh I
think that answers the question yeah
thank you that's perfectly clear thank
you Mr seor other questions from the
committee
uh representative
warry uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you secretary for take my question here
um just we we've had a couple of uh
forensic audits of a particular
community in the past where there's been
sort of redundant non-compliance how how
would you advise handling those
situations and what did the Secretary of
State's office and the Attorney
General's office do in that particular
circumstance for the longest time we
never had to use monitors uh because of
situations that occurred in polling
places and more recently there have
been situations that have been
identified
as going Beyond just normal technical
failures or uh you know errors but uh
just actions of election officials that
were not appropriation not appropriate
and um and and inv violation of more
significant parts of the election laws
and when that occurs uh we're supposed
to put monitors in the polling place and
so over the last two or three election
Cycles now you know we've had monitors
probably in two maybe three polling
places in a given election there is one
town in particular that has had monitors
now in repeated elections and and we're
taking
Progressive addal steps to try and deal
with the issues there um ultimately the
towns have have a responsibility in this
too and the people that they elect to
those positions have to be qualified and
the members of the community the voters
in that Community need to recognize when
those jobs are not being properly
executed and and make the required
changes um I know that the the Attorney
General's office is the enforcement arm
of the election law
they are the ones that will conduct any
investigations and they will make uh
decisions based on those
investigations and uh there have been a
couple of instances where election
officials have been actually removed
from office because of uh inappropriate
activity to the tune of just mishandling
individuals votes voters votes or trying
to cover up flaws uh in their process so
uh um you we continue to tighten tighten
too yes do you think
in those extreme situations that you
just described that punitive measures
ought to be put in
place yes and I think they are in place
uh they the punitive measures were
office representative Gilmore
thank you uh Dave we're just talking
about basically this bill is just poting
local elected officials not State
personnel as I understand it would you
agree with that I I think that's true
you know I I think that all of us have
to be accountable but we have to be
accountable in the appropriate way but
that was about law commission process
and okay thank
you further questions uh representative
prudo mban thank you uh I don't want to
minimize the problems that have been
discussed in this proposed bill I think
they are very important but I go back to
some of what you're saying and how it
applied in my own Community where I had
some concerns about
election uh some violations in election
law and it didn't make much it didn't
get a lot of traction let's say until
the AG in your
office after their investigation had uh
a monitor sent to my community and that
action
was kind of embarrassing and that got
the attention of the public would you
say that going through that process and
things did improve in my community
thankfully but would you say that going
through that process is the best way to
draw attention to it that's what I found
in my community well I I think it is a
good way to address it and as you
mentioned it you know the community
should be embarrassed if they have to
have a
monitor um there is a bit of an issue
with the monitor process itself and that
is finding individuals that are
qualified to be monitors in a polling
place on Election Day because the pool
of people that would have that
experience and expertise are serving as
election officials during an election so
we have uh
you know we have used some elderly
attorneys in the past that have had
election experience and we've tried to
use some young attorneys in my office
you know trying to give them some
exposure to these processes but they
were on a sharp learning curve as well
so um you know we continue to we
continue to
evolve further questions from the
committee
if not uh I guess not well thank you
very much Mr secretary always a pleasure
to see you here always a pleasure to
brandano thank you thank you for being
here
today thank you my name is Al brand Deno
I'm from Kensington New Hampshire
and I'm kind of disappointed because I
look around me in the past last four
years this room would be
packed and that's not the case anymore
because people have lost
confidence because for the last four
years when we came before this committee
not many not not not a handful of the
bills of the 40 things that we brought
up for election integrity was addressed
and and respectfully to um to secretary
scanland he had a voter confidence
committee where hundreds of people
across the state
attended ask him what happened with the
results what actions have they taken so
sadly this is where we're at and it's
very frustrating but I'm here to do the
best I can on behalf of the people who
have given
up first of all this this audit happened
uh this citizen audit happened after the
rec the recount election
uh of of um senator who was running at
the time L
gulo about 50 people joined in on the
recount on from L's Community there was
seven towns 50 people came together on
the recount that happened at the
Secretary of State's Archive Building
during that process we became motiv not
only motivated but horrified of what we
witnessed from taped one of the big
things in the contention for me in
hearing secretary scandin is that he's
missing a very important point and that
is chain of custody chain of custody is
broken you can't count anything in fact
if chain of custody is broken it's all
broken you can't say well the boxes were
broken or we maped them or we use the
wrong tape and it's unacceptable once
the chain of custody the rest of this is
incidental it really doesn't matter
chain of custody is everything and we
should be really focused on that and in
the so after that process about eight
people came together on Lou's behalf and
went through about 800 hours of work and
you'll find it here and I'll produce it
for you every every uh complaint in this
is been verified and we have the
documentation with pictures and rsas
laws not just infractions but rsas that
have been violated you'll find that
there's some towns like exitor over over
and over and over they've been noticed
by the attorney general and Secretary of
State we can go on and on and I'll
produce this for you but every thing
that you find in here we have produced
in paper form with as actual evidence of
violations of rsas not just incidental
things or policy procedures or failures
so I want to make that
clear um the second part here that
really concerns me is that if if we
don't do something and we can continue
on the same path that we just say you
know it's okay they minor infractions
and nothing's going to happen doesn't
matter what's what's going to happen
where is where are we now like I said
I'm one person here there used to be
this place you remember it you were here
it was packed nobody believes anybody
when you take it to the community when
you take it to the ballot law commission
and they take send it to the attorney
general and nothing they're not going to
investigate because if you look at the
Attorney General letter he says
specifically it's not up to us you
didn't point out the person if you look
at what he said you didn't point out the
person that you want to claim violated
the law that's not that's not my duty
we're citizens if we that would be
Vigilantes and it's unfair to understand
that that's what he said and in in my on
you know non- lawyer language that's
unacceptable the people came together
did this work gave it to them and
nothing happened and they told us you
didn't identify the person who committed
the crime well we just let you know that
somebody was robbing the bank right
that's all we don't know who it was we
saw the car drive away but that's not
our
job so you have to excuse my I hope my
harshness and my passion but I'm really
this a lot of work from a lot of people
and they're and they're quitting because
they see no hope and I only see the Hope
in this committee that you will pass
this bill no one's out to hurt anybody
that's not doing anything habitual
offenders need to be taken care of it
can't continue like
this I'll take any
questions thank you very much do we have
questions from the
committee okay representative wood thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question and off for the hard work
you've been doing how do you see this
bill helping um you said that you
haven't seen any action how do you see
this bill making a difference please
because if you look past the last four
years what's come out of this committee
is really nothing for the only thing
that's really come out that has actually
hurt us I think is hp1 154 and I there's
a whole that is a dis that was a a bill
that was hidden within a health care
bill which changed 22 election laws
which frustrated so many people who come
here every day and try to do the work of
the citizen so what happens is this is a
starting point for people to have hope
hey all we're asking for is that there
is a review of the rules we we because
training let's be honest is not Vol it's
only voluntary right I mean it's not
mandatory I don't know I I believe the
the the the training rates are less than
50% I think the secretary of state will
have to tell me of the people who
participate so we have a a training
issue as well um but there's a habitual
offender issue
and also a chain of custody we really
need to crack down on the proper chain
of custody because if you don't know
what's in the boxes it doesn't matter
what the count
is thank
committee uh appears not thank you very
today
um we have a another pink card uh Diane
fiser
today is would you uh press the button
on your microphone can see how good I am
at this um M Mr scamman said Secretary
of State uh I am a citizen and I make
mistakes but my name is Diane fiser and
I'm from Hamstead New Hampshire and I'm
going to tell you a little story I came
home from a trip a few days ago and I
had no hot water the pipes had Frozen I
called my son and asked him to come over
and he used some kind of a heat lamp or
whatever and got the water flowing and
then we found it was fine and then we
went through the house and we looked
around at the pipes to determine whether
or not there were any leaks or breaks
and as he said we need to make sure of
this before anything and more damage
happens well I look at this this
committee and I am really thrilled to be
in front of you and AUST Committee of
people that can make a difference here
in our state of New Hampshire and what
we're doing I look at this system as a
chance to look at a leak and make sure
it's not there I knew something was
wrong we know something is wrong I have
this I have pictures on my phone of when
we were there in the archives building
and when we spoke and we told people of
what we found and we weren't looking to
blame people we weren't looking to to
make fun of people or look to penalize
people we wanted them to see isn't that
something we do all of the time isn't
that what we have heard so desperately
if you see something say something there
is not one person I would imagine in
this room that has not heard that or
have we not listened to it and known of
the importance and what it is well just
like I saw something when no water came
out only on one side I saw something
something here and I have seen it
consistently through many times many
elections whether they be recounts or
things in my own town or other towns I
was brought into this and looking at it
when I had as they say no skin in the
game I'm from Hampstead I'm not from
exor I'm not from these areas where
others were represented and were talking
I am from America I am a US citizen I am
a New Hampshire Citizen and and I want
and I pray that you listen to us that
you look at this if you haven't seen it
you should take the time and you will
see the documentation you will see as Al
has said 700 800 hours and I believe
it's more of people that came and gave
of their own time I'm a grandmother I
started out with this because of wanting
things for my children for my
grandchildren I then it went on bigger
it's from more than my town other towns
it is for the country in general it is
for everyone for all of our lives for
our very Liberty we are here we are
asked to support our state to do our
duty and our duty is to help keep the
election process open fair and another
reason and I was listening to what the
Secretary of State said we do not want
to be punitive and yet and yet a couple
of sentence later he said yeah we did
take punitive damages against some
people that there was a problem with
recognize so there is and what are those
damages I mean are we we're not talking
about throwing somebody in jail or are
we talking about stand in the corner we
are just saying there might be some
repercussions just pay attention maybe a
time out but please just look at what
you're doing try to be careful and as I
was mentioned or heard before that less
I was told the percentage was 30% of
people that are trained because that's
how many people volunteer their time and
we understand it so I thank you very
much for my uh speaking just as I am
just as a citizen your average
grandmother but someone who cares very
much and very deeply and very
passionately about this and I thank you
for your time thank you do you wish to
take questions from the committee sure
answers uh I don't see any questions
from the committee so thank you very
much for your testimony okay you're
quite uh representative gzowski could
you get the blue sheet I don't see any
testify and so I will close the public
hearing for HB 448 and since we're
behind
schedule uh I will be opening up the
next public hearing I I do want to say
that we have two more bills that were
scheduled before noon
I should read that I guess for HP 448 we
had four people who wanted to express
their opinion without uh testifying
three were in favor of this bill and one
was opposed to
it all right I'm going to we have two
more Bill two more bills to have public
hearing on public hearings on before
noon and I'm going to behind schedule
we're going to cover both of those
before we break for lunch thank you so
that said I have at uh
11:45 I am opening the public hearing
for HB
626 yeah I suppose I should have
adjourned the previous public hearing
first that's
yes representative McFarland please uh
begin your testimony thank you good
morning Mr chairman I will try and keep
you uh or get or get you a little bit
closer back to schedule with the next
two bills thank you uh so good morning
Mr chairman members committee I'm
representative Donald McFarland from
Orange I thank you for the opportunity
to present House Bill 626 today this
testimony represents My Views and most
importantly the views and interests of
my constituents whom I serve in the
towns of Alexandria Bristol Bridgewater
Kanan Dorchester Enfield Grafton gron
Hebron and the small town that secretary
scanland referred to earlier orange uh
my testimony is not made on behalf of
any private employer nor should it be
construed to represent the views of any
of my employers to the bill elections
and you should have one sheet that came
around one way one sheet that came
around the other way I have provided uh
the the chairman and the clerk with a
slightly larger package of exhibits uh
elections are the Cornerstone of our
democracy and election security is vital
to maintaining trust in that process
computers are deeply embedded in voter
registration checklist maintenance
ballot issuance vote counting and
reporting to protect protect the public
trust these systems must not only be
secure but must also be seen as secure
New Hampshire has long been a leader in
election Integrity since 1994 we've had
the first in the nation paper trail law
last November our historic election saw
nearly 75% of eligible voters at the
polls one of the highest participation
rates in the nation and these figures
reflect the Public's trust in our
process and the excellent work of the
secretary
this bill Builds on that Foundation it
allows security researchers to assess
the vulnerabilities and ensures findings
are transparently reported by
identifying and fixing potential flaws
we bolster public trust and prevent Bad
actors from exploiting weaknesses
importantly this is a nonpartisan Bill
elections may be partisan but the
Machinery that powers them must not be
this bill does not assert any current
deficiencies but instead ensures
continued trust and resilience I urge
the Secretary of State's office to go
further than the bill mandates including
creating a test instance of the voter
registration database so that
researchers May readily assess the user
interfaces for Town clerks supervisors
of the checklist and so forth
transparency and security go hand inand
and this initiative would help to
position New Hampshire as a national
leader in election security I've
provided each of you with a copy of the
National Association of secretaries of
State issue briefing for further context
and background and I'm happy to yield to
questions uh and to remain available for
further uh followup after public
testimony okay thank you do we have any
committee seeing none thank you very
testimony I'm sorry I missed that
representative
lry oh everyone's trying to get my
attention here representative C you're
recognized uh thank you chairman thank
you for taking my question uh would this
have anything to do with voting machines
themselves yeah it's a great question
Alvin the way that it's written uh it
certainly would cover those but the the
main focus of this the main thrust of
this is not on voting machines the main
thrust of this is that if a researcher
is aware of a problem we want to know
about it we want them to have an Avenue
to be able to report that and I think
we've had an awful lot of focus uh in
the past in this state on our voting
machines we have that paper trail law
that I talked about so of course if if
somebody tomorrow was to identify a a
real security weakness in the voting
machines I'm quite sure that the
secretary would like to hear about it
and they could use this kind of a
disclosure mechanism to make that
disclosure uh however the thing that was
most in my mind uh when drafting this
bill was that we have had uh slightly
less Focus we've had certainly uh
testing performed by the secretary's
office and on their behalf half by
contractors but in the public eye we've
had less focus on things like the voter
registration
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony I have no other red cards for
the uh people to testify oh
minute Mr chairman I will fill out a pen
card I promise okay
just just briefly I I uh I was
interested in hearing the testimony on
the bill uh I think it's a good idea the
one concern that I would have is that if
uh there are outside interests that are
looking at
vulnerabilities uh of our election
systems that there be some kind of a
mechanism to allow the Secretary of
State to hear those cure them and then
make them public so that we don't have a
system that is potentially vulnerable
uh in a public way
um I think that's something that could
easily be worked into the bill okay
thank you for that uh will you take a
question on that or uh representative C
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary for taking my question um it I
just in reading the bill it looks like
it should be somewhat expensive to do
this but there's no fiscal note on this
bill uh what's your take on that
uh deputy secretary Hennessy just came
in she's been drafting the fiscal notes
on the bills I'm not sure if she put one
together on this or not but she'd be in
comment
what's
what who's looking to be recognized you
sry excuse me uh Mr
chairman go ahead thank you um thank you
secretary scan so I just want to make
sure I've got it's call it an
understanding so your office is okay
with the bill but you would like us to
add a provision about first you get to
fix the problem and then disclose it and
I totally understand that but I just
want to make sure that we're on the same
page as you're fine with the F fine with
the concept you want that added in yeah
okay
okay thank you any other questions for
the
secretary right seeing
none uh represent your head would you
sheet got the uh the blue sheet there is
no one who wished to State an opinion
and did not wish to testify so it's
blank thank
you okay uh online there were three in
support five opposed with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
626 I'll open the public hearing on
House Bill 327 FN relative to filings
for the office of uh for office and
witnessing affidavits and recognized
representative McFarland for the purpose
thank you Mr chairman uh it looks like
we're uh uh doing doing good we're
making up some time here uh again uh
representative McFarland from Orange uh
and thank you for the opportunity to
present HB 327 and again this testimony
is not made on behalf of any private
employer nor should it be construed to
represent the views of any of my
employers uh this bill addresses two
practical challenges in the election
filing process in the the filing process
for candidates for elections that have
caused unnecessary confusion delays and
expense for candidates as well as
difficulties for Town officials under
current law candidates must file their
paperwork during a limited 10 calendar
day period uh per RSA 65514 as we all
know in many towns this works smoothly
but in small towns with part-time clerks
uh there can be unique challenges
Clerk's offices may only be open once or
twice during the filing window or not at
all due to illness or other unforeseen
circumstances for candidates this can
create significant barriers to
completing their filings additionally
there is a reasonable expectation that
candidates filing in person should be
able to present themselves before the
town clerk or their deputy and complete
their part of the process typically the
forms themselves are obtained from the
town clerk while this process works
smoothly in many towns problems have
Arisen because some Town clerks and
their deputies are not notaries public
when a notary is unavailable candidates
have been told their filings were
complete only later to learn that the
Secretary of State's office had rejected
them these candidates are then forced to
scramble to meet deadlines take time off
work and incur additional costs to fix
these issues the challenges are not
partisan they are avoidable with minor
changes to current law House Bill 327
proposes two simple practical Solutions
number one for filing with the Secretary
of State in towns where Clerk's Offices
hours are limited candidates would have
the option to file directly with the
Secretary of State here in conquer this
ensures all candidates have equal access
to the filing process regardless of
their Town
circumstances number two Town clerks
would be able to witness affidavits
without regard to whether or not they
are notaries public this streamlines the
process in small towns where the clerk
or his Deputy is not a notary these
changes are practical and narrowly
tailored to address the specific issues
which have Arisen without imposing any
significant new burdens on the parties
involved filing for public office is a
Cornerstone of our democratic system we
have a duty to ensure that candidates
for office can navigate this process
fairly and
effectively these proposed changes do
not alter the responsibilities of
candidates or the core requirements of
the process instead they provide
practical solutions to real barriers
that have Arisen under the current
statutes and importantly this bill
upholds the Integrity of our election
systems while ensuring access and
fairness for all I've spoken with the
secretary to my understanding he
supports this proposal House Bill 327 is
a non-controversial common sense bill
that promotes good governance and I urge
the committee to recommend this bill for
Passage and consider its suitability for
the consent calendar I welcome any
questions and I'm happy to provide
further clarification thank you thank
you um I'll start off the first question
uh and tip my hand to a question I think
I'll ask the secretary or his
representative um I I don't I don't love
the idea of having like three separate
days 18 hours I honestly I'd rather just
say you can register your town clerk or
you can register in the Secretary of
State's office and just get rid of the
convoluted how many hours you open how
many days are you open that will
inevitably cause a headache would that
be an issue for you as a sponsor if we
just went
to yep you can register the secretary
state's office or you can register your
town clerk yeah it certainly wouldn't be
a concern for me chairman uh I I think
the reason that I put it in in that way
is because I do recognize that there's
the potential uh for increased volume
here in conquer and in conversations
with the secretary uh we we felt that
that was uh a very reasonable uh you
know way to to define the level I I
think I you should probably have that
conversation with him we will which is
why I kind of backwardly asked him
through you so he knows he can think
think about it um uh any other questions
from the committee representative
Bay thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um isn't it also
would you consider it a practical
alternative to um require Town clerks to
be notor
public it's a great question and and I I
figured that somebody would ask that I
let me tell you uh I'm going to make
reference again to my town uh by way of
example and this is not limited to me
I've heard similar issues from from
other uh candidates and and uh elected
officials whom we all know um but in the
town of orange that secretary scanland
mentioned earlier uh we are a small town
uh we typically pay very nominal um you
know salaries or or or alley rates
whatever to our officials and it is very
hard to find people to fill those roles
um for a number of years we have had
Town clerks who uh were not thrilled
about doing the job but were happy to to
dedicate themselves to doing that job
and who did not have uh a notary public
uh qualification so I think in answer to
your question if we were to make that
stipulation just as when we make other
stipulations that put additional burdens
on these officials all you are doing is
uh causing fewer and fewer people to be
willing to step forward uh in their
local
Town well uh sorry further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
representative McFarland um thank
Hennessy thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Aaron Hennessy
I am the deputy secretary of state and
our office supports this bill we
currently take um filings for office for
any County officers uh state senators um
and every office above that um we do
feel like this would make our office
busier during the filing period however
um it's our job to process all of those
filings at some point anyway um so we
are happy to take on this additional um
the add the additional filings uh to the
chair and his question about opening up
to all Representatives I did have a
concern about the language in the bill
normally and routinely um just our
office would have to do research for
each rep that came into file to make
sure that their clerk normally and
routinely was only open under the
language of this law um which would be
difficult because we only have access to
their website we really don't know what
their normal routine hours are so if
that could be fixed or just removed in
general that would be appreciated I'm
happy to take questions questions from
the committee um yes representative
C uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
deputy secretary for taking my question
um do you have any concerns about a uh
notary I am not what I can tell you is
that if you require a clerk to be a
notary there is a there's a timeline
that it takes to become a notary so if
there're uh SW if a deputy's sworn in a
new Deputy is sworn in it will take
several months to become a notary and
there may be a filing period in that
time in which
um somebody comes into their office so I
believe this is like a legislative
priority versus a and it's specifically
for the filings and not any
other um option so all right thank you
uh further questions and um I don't I
don't know if you or the secretary want
to address my question which is can we
just stop being treated like second
class citizens of State reps and file
with the
Senators Mr chairman I think the answer
to that is yes we can do that and I did
want to add although I'm not advocating
for a June primary but if there happened
to be
[Laughter]
one if if there happened to be a filing
period in March it would certainly be
very convenient for uh incumbents to
file in our
office just a quick answer to
representative C's question
um you have to pass a background check
to become a notary
um and if you don't pass you have to get
the approval from an executive counselor
so it is possible that there may be some
clerks that get elected that have
something in their background that could
prevent that prevent them from becoming
a
notary yes representa C uh just as a
followup on that
um it is there any concern that you
would have about a person not being a
notary because as I recall when I filed
I didn't the paper wasn't notorized
I think on those types of documents an
election official can sign in L of a
notary I'll have to check the statute
but
um I I I would note that election
officials are
elected
so it's not like they haven't undergone
some scrutiny um any other uh questions
from the
committee okay uh seeing none thank you
is there anyone else uh here who wishes
to speak speak on this representative
gusovsky I get it am am I getting worse
as the day goes on yeah I
am that felt so good about it at the
beginning I was like I got it uh online
there was four in support three opposed
um with that going going to get this
blue sheet here is there anybody on
there representative okay it's blank um
okay so we are going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 327 we're only
running four minutes behind thank you
nobody for opening the primary debate
uh about had a heart
attack um we're going to reconvene um at
10:5 so we'll push back 5 minutes
because we're 5 minutes behind give an
hour for lunch uh for the purpose of
house bills 6:30 um one quick
announcement um I have put on my
campaign website which is the only
website I have access to um a calendar
so you can see all of the bills um when
they've been scheduled uh if they've
been scheduled where they are in the
process uh that is what I use to track
the bills it's the same sheet it's
nothing special um but I wanted to make
that available to the public um that was
the only way that I could really do that
so sorry on my campaign website um
there's nothing else on there other than
the calendar but if you go barry4 R
nh.com forc calendar uh you can see all
75 bills uh have they been scheduled
have they had a hearing when it is all
there it's not there's no spin on it
it's just straight where we are but
that's what I use to organize so I'll
see you guys at
e
okay it's 105 we're going yet going I'm
going to open up the public hearing for
the house election law committee for
Bill House Bill 630 FN preventing the
dissemination of deep fake materials of
political candidates before an election
representative Corman is recognized for
introduction thank you Mr chairman for
those who don't know me I'm
representative Tom Corman I represent
the fight and 15th Grafton 15 which is
Ward three of the city of Lebanon the
beautiful city of Lebanon uh I need to
give you some background first about
myself myself and and how I got involved
in all this I'm an Emeritus professor of
computer science at Dartmouth College
where I was on the faculty for 29 and a
half years and I chaired the computer
science department for six years from uh
2009 to
2015 so uh as department chair I
certainly had to keep my eye on what was
going on throughout the entire field of
computer science but actually I've been
in computer science since
1974 and you don't need a computer to
determine that's over
years uh I have uh eecs electrical
engineering and computer science degrees
from Princeton and from MIT I got my
masters and PhD from MIT where I spent
eight years I'm actually quite well
known within Computer Sciences the lead
author of a textbook introduction to
algorithms I say all this because I have
a background in computer science it's
not in artificial intelligence uh which
this bill is somewhat about and it's not
in
digital media but again I've had to keep
my eye on all this and I've been
tracking all this for a long time so
last year this committee had the bill HB
1596 which prohibits deceptive AI
generated deep fakes during elections I
co-sponsored that bill uh it was
sponsored by representative Brennan I
co-sponsored it in large part because I
have tracked AI since I entered grad
school in 1984 so that was 4 1 years
ago and I didn't do research in AI as I
said but I've seen the explosive growth
in AI over the last decade and we know
that AI is capable of creating deep
fakes that can easily fool many people
very easily and the bill from last year
HB 1596 allows for injunctive relief for
and other relief for deceptive deep
fakes within 90 days of an election and
it allows for deep fakes that are
labeled as such so if somebody creates a
deep fake and says this uh was created
with artificial intelligence it uh
allows somebody who deep who distributes
a deep fake unknowingly so if if you
receive a deep fake you don't know it's
a deep fake you don't suspect it is and
you send it on you're not liable for
anything and for news stories that are
about deep fakes that would show the
Deep fake so if Channel 9 says you know
here's a story about a deep fake and
they show the Deep fake but they made it
clear that they believe this is deep
fake that's okay and also for satire and
parody so the sponsor and I worked with
members of this committee and with the
Senate to amend the bill to the point
that people on both sides of the aisle
were satisfied with the bill and it has
been enacted it is currently RSA
664 colon
14c so that's where we are right now
last fall I was at a talk at Dartmouth
given by professor hany fari
Professor freed is a good friend of mine
former colleague at Dartmouth for 20
years and he's now a professor at the
University of California at Berkeley he
is an expert in digital media forensics
which is determining whether media is
genuine or digitally altered or
digitally created and when I say he's an
expert he might even be the world's
expert he's certainly one of the most
brilliant people I've ever known and I
knew a lot of people at MIT who were
just you know several standard deviation
above the likes of me and he's in that
category brilliant brilliant man and uh
with the chair's permission I'll be
reading a letter from him into the
record for a few minutes you all have
copies of the of the letter I told
Professor fed about this bill that we'
passed and some others related to Ai and
his reaction was that the bill 1596 did
not go far enough he said it's become
too easy to alter digital media without
AI so using tools such as Photoshop a
good Photoshop expert can create a
pretty good deep fake that will fool a
lot of
people so after this conversation I
looked more closely at hb1
1596 and it defines four terms synthetic
media AI generative Ai and deep fake
seems reasonable but when I looked at
the rest of the bill I realized that the
term synthetic media did not appear any
anywhere in the bill after it was
defined it wasn't used anywhere else in
the bill so the bill actually is really
only about deep fakes generated with
AI so the bill before you 630 uses the
definition of synthetic media to also
Define synthetic media technology as any
digital technology that can be used to
produce synthetic media including
artificial intelligence or Genera AI so
synthetic media technology can include
AI behind it but it doesn't have to so
if you think of Photoshop or even Garage
Band right that that can be synthetic
media something produced by synthetic
media so everywhere else in RSA
66414 C that mentions deep fakes
produced using AI or generative AI this
bill changes it to deep fakes you
produced using synthetic media
technology so that non AI software is
covered as well so that's the the
purpose of this bill to expand the Deep
fakes covered in election season to
include anything produced by synthetic
media technology not just AI based
synthetic media technology and with the
chair's permission I would like to read
fared let's I I would I would prefer not
um we have the copy of the letter um it
will be a part of the public record the
clerk has it um but we have a lot of
bills and I don't want to how many other
people actually let me see that how many
people have signed up for
this just one actually it's fine there
just one other person signed up so not a
big deal we're it's not going to if it
was going to throw us off I would say no
but you're fine thank you so this is
from Professor free dated January 25th I
write in support of HB 630 FN I have
read this bill and I agree with the
sponsor that it strengthens HB 1596 from
2024 in an important way for background
I've been conducting research in digital
media forensic since 1999 with over 200
peer-reviewed Publications in the field
I'm frequently called upon as an expert
witness in cases in which the veracity
of digital media is at question I have
testified many times before the US
Senate US House EU Parliament and UK
Parliament on issues of digital media
integrity and appropriate regulatory
interventions I was on the faculty at
Dartmouth College for 20 years which is
where I met representative then
Professor Corman and I've been on the
faculty at the University of California
Berkeley since
2019 HB 1596 prohibited deceptive deep
fakes within 90 days of an election but
it prohibited only deep fakes generated
by artificial intelligence this is an
overly and unnecessarily narrow
definition of deep fakes that does not
contend with the reality of today's
landscape of manipulated and malicious
content digital media technology has
evolved to the point that many users can
create convincing fake media that are so
realistic that determining that they are
specifically generated with AI
Technologies is challenging and requires
highly specialized software in addition
there are many ways for creating
misleading or malicious content that
does not require the use of AI
precautions against selection
interference should focus on the
malicious content and not on the
specific mechanism or technique used to
create that content HB 630 FN recognizes
these realities by defining synthetic
media technology to include any digital
technology that can produce synthetic
media and by prohibiting deceptive deep
fakes created by synthetic media
technology during election season
instances of deep fakes in the public
sphere abound both domestically and
internationally and as you know in New
Hampshire deep fakes have already found
their way into elections by expanding
the scope of deep fakes to include all
synthetic media HB 630 FN will provide
additional safeguards in elections
signed H fed Professor UC
Berkeley and with that I am happy to
take questions okay other questions from
the
committee uh yes representative wood
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
the take my question um I definitely on
the same page I I didn't understand when
they focused this bill on AI versus the
other techniques out there um why does
Bill even necessary you know to me um
digitally I can create Illusions even
without using the per person's uh uh
Voice or fa features just by using the
media out there saying that he said this
showing examples of other people saying
there's so many ways to create an
illusion I think this bill missed all of
that stuff I think most of this is
already covered if you're smart enough
to find these things or willing to find
these things but just because we got
some technology that makes it easier
doesn't mean that this hasn't been done
for years and is covered already in
election law as far as I understand as
long as you can prove it you got the
same problem here why is this sorry to
be this is more my opinion you I
apologize to the
board yes thank you I'm I'm amazed you
let me go that long thank thank you Mr
chairman yeah I got it uh how do you
think that's different sorry how do how
do you think it's different than what I
just did thank you all right thank you
for the
question what what the bill from last
year did was it focused on on synthetic
media generated by
Ai and it didn't cover any other
synthetic media so if you were really
good with I don't know Garage Band you
could take clips of me talking and just
make it sound like I'm saying something
I've never said or if you're really good
with Photoshop you could create an image
of me robbing a
bank which I have not
done and allegedly I have allegedly not
done and what this bill does is it just
says all right if you're using other
software other digital uh media software
to create it then then that would be
covered under this bill um I mean you're
right that these things could be done
and and what we're trying to do is cover
them under the law as far as whether
that's already covered under election
law you know you're the election law
committee I hope you know the laws I'm
I'm I'm in Science Tech and energy I
know the energy laws so um I'll have to
leave it to you whether it's already
covered um the one thing I would uh say
then
is well was the part about AI already
covered why did we need that
bill I love answering the question with
the questions my one of my favorite
things to do um representative weary uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
just so in in I don't know if you have
your bill in front of you but um so
under synthetic media in one onea it
talks about other digital
technology would would that
but there it's talking about the media
being created so it implies that digital
techn I'm
just I'm I'm loathed to add uh
definitions if we can avoid that and and
I'm and then is is there any specific
justification for a a deep deep fake
down in line 23 as as opposed to just a
message that um you know uh synthetic
media message you know something along
those lines I I I'm
just uh cautious
about
um trying to find
two uh find a point on this so do you
think digital technology is included in
this initial
definition in the initial definition of
of synthetic media so it talks about
adversarial Network techniques it is
included in the in the original
definition of synthetic media however um
as I mentioned when I read the bill when
I read uh 1596 from last year although
synthetic media is defined it isn't used
anywhere else in the
bill so you know it's it's just a dead
end definition so my main purpose with
this bill was to actually incorporate
the notion of synthetic media into what
would be covered and the places uh where
the original bill and the current law
say message M um I suggested that it
should say deep fake because a deep fake
means that you're showing uh you're
creating media that shows somebody doing
or saying something that they didn't do
or
say okay but you gotta get you gotta get
question quickly on this so would you
have any objections if we just send send
said instead of message we said
synthetic media and then instead of
artificial intelligence or generative AI
if we just said digital
technology
um I don't know that I would object I
don't see um I don't see where that
provides an advantage over what is in
the bill okay thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you um only one other person sign to
um good afternoon chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Olivia zinc executive director at
open democracy I live in Franklin um and
I'm testifying in support of House Bill
6 um30 um as technology rapidly advances
artificial intelligence and deep fa are
becoming more pervasive in our society
um on my phone I have a a voicemail that
I was left before the primary on my home
voicemail um and it doesn't have a
disclosure of who paid for it um so this
this bill what it does is just requires
disclosure of of anything that's created
um using using this it doesn't prohibit
people from doing it just requires
disclosure disclosure um and we support
adding these definitions because of
photos videos audio audio recorders
could mimic anything um to more accurate
and
believable um could you imagine if you
lost election because somebody said you
were saying something so say we said
Shan Barry likes Mars Bars have no idea
if you like that kind of candy bar or
not um but people could make up whatever
message they want and distribute it um
and say don't vote for this candidate
because of any reason and so I think um
I want to thank this committee for
working really hard in a bipartisan way
to pass a bill uh such as this um and
this bill just strengthens the work that
was done last year
um as as technology evolves so um we
urge you to to support um moving this
bill forward and happy to take any
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um all
right is there anyone else present who
wishes to speak to this bill I don't see
any thank you um with have the blue
sheet it's blank um online there were 36
in support Z opposed um the committee
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 6:30 U the committee will
stand in recess for 8 minutes until 1:30
you did request
[Music]
aill I'm not going toow ai ai generated
course
e
um we're not doing it here right now I
the they just gave us all the fiscal
notes so instead of passing this stack
of stacks what I'm going to do is I'm
I'm just going to lay them out on this
Center table here and you can come and
get them at your leisure um because
otherwise you're going to be yeah not
fun so uh I'm GNA do that and we got
so
e
okay it's 130
uh we're going to open up the house
election Law Public hearing for House
Bill 474 requiring a second witness at
the counting of right in votes and
recogn
oh uh representative Burnham is
recognized uh for inter of the bill and
I guess I will take some notes I didn't
I didn't equate
that
ready I'll be back yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you committee members
I'm representative claudian Burnham and
I'm in support obviously of HB
474 which is um just a simple line
requiring second witness at the counting
of R and votes this bill closes the Gap
and bipartisan wri in and overvote
determination currently when a person
writes in a vote the moderator is given
the authority to look at the screen and
determine the votes intention and
adjudicate the ballot without a second
set of
Eyes by correcting this Gap this will
allow for a bipartisan review to be
done the second witness must be either a
selectman or a town clerk per the New
Hampshire
Constitution please vote a to pass to
help close this Gap and be sure our
right in votes are approved by count and
count and counted fairly thank you okay
and will you be taking questions sure
all right are there questions from the
Comm
representative Grill we haven't heard
from you
today um hi uh my question is um for
nonpartisan elections um and offices
that are elected on a nonpartisan basis
how would that uh party registration be
determined um like I sorry that was
probably confusing wording I guess like
for the local elections is that what
you're pertaining to like school board
or yeah I guess I'm just a a little
confused
of if um if that would be an effect for
all elections only the partisan ones um
and a lot of times these offices are
elected without party registration so
you could get for example a slate of all
Republican uh moderators clerks or
another town all Democrat uh moderators
and clerks um I
guess how would that person be selected
in in those instances um well I believe
that there are some towns that are
bipartisan
so I think it should just be consistent
all the way around um and it just kind
of shows um a balance to the system by
choosing it that
way
okay doing double duty here
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question uh
this sort of follows on uh
representative Grill's question what
happens if the moderator is registered
as an independent who would be the
well that's a good question I would just
assume that it would be another part a
different party member doesn't
necessarily mean one of the as long
somebody different and not another
independent maybe that's not
clear I was just trying to figure out
what you intended I got to do ask for a
followup there they they they spoke with
us about that at the chair's meeting
questions okay seeing none thank you
representative Burnham and I'm going to
email you my very short notes thank you
um next up is bro Dees with the New
Association welcome to election
law thank you Mr chairman thank you to
the committee for taking my testimony um
so the New Hampshire
municip sorry excuse me the New
Hampshire Municipal Association is
opposed to House Bill 474
um the addition of the of the last
sentence is a little bit confusing for
us to try to interpret um our current
interpretation is that this is um
implying that folks who are moderators
inherently have a um that they've
declared a party and that therefore they
would have to find someone else of the
opposing party um there can be sometimes
uh multiple opposing parties in a state
right now though the two um recognized
parties are Republican and Democratic so
I guess the assumption would be if
you're a republican you need to find a
Democrat if you are a Democrat then you
need to find a republican to partake in
the process of reviewing the uh righten
votes um our concern is the burden um
the vagueness and how that is done it's
not really entirely um spelled out how
exactly a moderator would appoint
someone would they swear them in as if
they were an assistant moderator those
are things that need to happen during
the election process those who are
working are sworn in by the town clerk
or by the moderator um you know prior to
the uh the election day begin
um aside from the additional burden um
moderators are elected and trusted
there's a reason why it's a nonpartisan
office um why people of all parties
serve in it um the voters they they
elect their moderators and um they trust
their moderators or another moderator
would run and the voters would replace
an existing moderator if they had a
problem with the way that they were um
conducting their business and running
the election of a community whether it
was a local election um or a state
election um additionally I just want to
flag that there are party poll Watchers
um and this is a very public process in
the state of New Hampshire so if you are
a Republican and you have a problem and
believe that you'd like to watch the
process closely you can and um vote
challenges can happen too so the
moderator has to do all this publicly
it's subjected to public scrutiny and um
either party that's on the ballot is
allowed to have a point poll Watchers at
the polling place um so for those
reasons um and because of these
additional burdens um we are currently
opposed to house po 474 and I'd be happy
to take any questions if you have any
thank you other questions from the
committee seeing Oh representative
seeing thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh would it be
helpful if the um town could grab an
extra computer monitor and plug it in so
that more people can see another screen
screen I don't know what the thank you
for the question representative I don't
know what the size of the screen is and
I'm not entirely sure what different
moderators do specifically um currently
at their different uh you know their
their election their polling places um
you know to ensure um public scrutiny of
the process but I would you know i'
would be hard pressed that a moderator
wouldn't let a pull Watcher or someone
who's like a ballot clerk be able to
watch that process um typically you know
the the right and votes are accounted by
ballot clerks um you know at the end
they count all the uh different how many
wrin there were and make sure everything
adds up so in the moderators it's their
job to interpret write and vote what the
intent of that vote was um who the vote
was for so we've seen AR rise of people
writing in votes for candidates who are
already on the ballot because they would
like to force a hand count vote for
those ballots and usually it's the
moderators going through um the wenss of
candidates that are already on the
ballot and basically saying yep that
that vote does count indeed for this
candidate that's on the ballot even
though it was a right end and um making
sure that everyone's vote is counted
during the process
followup absolutely
um as as I understand it the uh computer
that comes with the voting machine at
least for the voting Works machine is
just a small laptop so it's kind of hard
to crowd a bunch of people around and
look over the shoulder of the moderator
while he's doing that okay um thank you
representative further questions from
the
committee representative
Gilmore thank
you um as a mo moderator um and uh who
was 12 years now
um I always assign my ballot clerks to
do the counting of the writing vote so
we our machine um doesn't have that
digital process hopefully next time it
will um so we have to do it by hand um
so do I understand this bill to say that
now I have to have all those writing
people to would have to have an a member
of the other party I don't even know the
party of my pow workers um I don't know
I just I'm sorry I guess I'm really just
s just talking sorry but is that your
understanding too or there you go there
you
go um the first one's free yeah I was G
um this specifically cites um ballot
counting device um so I would assume it
would only account in those situations
where a municipality is using a ballot
counting device um that would my
interpretation say
printed you got to ask for a follow I'm
sorry I'm sorry Mr I I I'm not the one
who cares about that think better I
understand you're right I've been talked
to
okay I'm good I'm good I'm good he's
good okay okay um any other questions
from the committee all right um thank
you sorry represent his you normally let
you go second I your car got bared I
apologize so you're up you should have
anyway good afternoon everyone Ain
Hennessy I'm the deputy secretary of
state so the legislation before you uh
strictly applies to the electronic Bal
accounting devices that digitally
display or print write-ins right now in
the state we only have one device that
does this this is the voting Works
device um in March it'll be
in it grows every day I want to say for
polling places um at March toown
elections that's just an estimate right
now and in the training process for
moderators and anyone who um learns
about the voting Works device we train
that when they do the adjudication
process of the write-ins which does come
up on a laptop screen um as
representative C did mention that they
are to do that in pairs so what someone
does the typing and someone confirms
that what was typed is what was written
on the screen um this is very similar to
the process that is used for paper
ballots when they look at a write in
where there's two people working
together um they're not done in um silos
where just one person calculates the
total rins um so it's a team process um
I do I am not opposed to putting in law
that it be a team process however um the
moderator is a non-partisan elected
official um and as it has been mentioned
um does not run as a um as a member of a
party they may be Undeclared voter um
and so the term opposing party would be
difficult in a lot of situations and
also politicize the moderator um which
we don't want to see in an election um
so I would just recommend some language
changes there um but in in regards to
having two people do it we do currently
train to that the moderator does have
the ability to assign this to someone
else so it's not necessarily the
moderator who is typing in on the
computer it may be one of her or his
assistants doing this so I just want to
make it clear it's not always the
moderator doing it um they are a
nonpartisan election official and we
currently do train to
this will you be taking questions I'm
happy to take questions are there
represent gimar uh preemptive you want
to turn your mic off or oh thank you
yeah because things happen um questions
from the committee for the deputy
secretary representative we you look
intrigued
uh thank you Mr chair thank you deputy
secretary for taking my question so um
there is a paragraph in 659 63 about
counting to be public um
perhaps uh
64a uh could be amended to convey
that the counting of these um right-end
vote should follow the principles
outlined in 659 63 although it may be
implied I'm not sure but
um um got to get to a question yes is
that you know would you see do you see
this counting in 6 in 65964 a consistent
with the counting to be public within
659 63 I think that would be actually
the appropriate question thank you for
the question representative I didn't
bring my law book so if you are seeing
that that is the exact statute where it
requires public counting then yes they
would this already has to be done in
public okay thank you further questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you I don't believe I have any
more pain cards um
representative gusowski gusowski I'm
getting worse I'm I'm trying I'm I'm I'm
trying real hard just be consistent
yeah I I I should just yeah just just
let it fly or or I could just just
butcher it in a way that's just
Smith um there was no one signed up uh
who did not
speak
online where did it go um online there
were four in support six in opposition
and with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill
474 um we've got 10 we've got five
minutes
so I would like to we're not going to
take a vote but I would like to uh go
into executive section for the purpose
of
discussing uh where is
it uh 327 which we heard earlier today
that's the that's the one about signing
up at the Secretary of State's office I
just like to get the committee's feel on
it we're not taking a vote but so um I'm
going to open up the executive section
for House Bill 327 FN relative to fine
for office and witnessing affidavits um
does anybody have any comments on this I
think I made my position pretty clear
which is I
think anyone should be able to do this
for any for for State Rep um does anyone
else have any concerns I'll I'll bring
that Amendment forward when we actually
execute but does anybody else have any
comments on
that representative C I kind of agree
with the idea of just saying the uh uh
Secretary of State's office can take
these at any time regardless whether the
uh town clerk has a limited hours okay
any other any other questions comments
representative um qua I almost blanked
on your
name I agree with representative C okay
any other question comments
representative Gilmore um having been to
Orange four times and four well three
times there was different clerks and
another time there was nobody and um
yeah I think it's a great Bill okay uh
um any other questions comments concerns
all right um with that I'll close I just
wanted to hear from the committee so
with that I'll close the um executive
session
on 3:27 I guess I'm technically
recessing it so recessing the executive
session for it um anything else we want
to talk
[Music]
about oh let's talk about well we have a
second I'm gonna open up the executive
session for House Bill 626 directing the
Secretary of State to implement a
vulnerability disclos osure program for
certain electronic systems um I believe
I have in my notes that the secretary
was in support yeah he's in suppor of
the idea but he wants a provision about
if a problem is discovered they're able
to fix it first um which seems very
reasonable to me if the secretary States
in support of it um I I I also think the
secretary's concern is very reasonable
which is hey if we do this and we find
something we probably shouldn't tell
people before we fix it um I think
that's actually pretty reasonable um
does anybody have any comments about
that they'd like to opine
on yes representative toner um I agree
with that the only time or the question
that I would have with that is if
there's any type of breach that happens
there is rsas associated with publicly
announcing breaches so I don't know if
that would conflict with that or not
might
not yeah that's that's an interesting
breaches okay um any other questions
comments
concerns on
this okay represent toner do you think
you can look into that with that r i I
have no clue about that RSA so I I
anything I say
is conjecture so yeah I'd be happy too
i' and I can send it to you but um it
might need a review by the secretary
yeah yeah it's fine yeah was well it's
not it's not an early bill so um okay
any other anyone anyone else wish to app
on that I just want to kind of get where
people's heads was that so that's
fine uh I'll close the exe I'll recess
the executive session for 6 House Bill
626 thanks for indulging me there um we
definitely don't have time to begin
discussing the signs on property that'll
take God knows how long so we won't we
won't start that discussion until we
hear the next bill because um we have
two minutes we
won't everyone in this room is going to
have a different standard for what
that's going to be so that'll be
interesting to watch that sort all right
I'll see you guys in uh basically I
Seconds
all right it's 150 um so we're going to
open up the house election Law Public
hearing for House Bill 389 requiring
candidates to attest that they have
spent uh no more not more than $1,000 in
an election and we will repres recognize
an
Alum alumnus of the committee
representative Howard it's good to see
you thank you so much uh honorable Mr
chair and uh committee members uh it's
good to be back I'm representative Heath
Howard I represent the towns of straford
and barington and straford District 4 uh
today I'm introducing HB
389 and it's a pretty simple bill it
requires uh anybody who doesn't spend or
receive $1,000 in an election period to
still file uh the thing is is in 2022 we
had
418 out of 893 state representative
candidates who did not file a single
report that's 47% of everybody who ran
uh and we had nine out of 65 Senate
candidates that's
14% so we had a significant amount of
people who didn't submit any sort of
financial
disclosure the thing is is that right
now because of the way that our paper
filing Works uh you don't necessarily
need to file a paper report but if you
go on to the online system instead you
have to file everything sequentially
meaning that you have to check off a
little check box that says that you
attest that you did not spend or receive
over $1,000 in that
period this would just make sure that
the process is the same it would ensure
compliance across the board make sure
that every single candidate is just
checking off a little box if they didn't
receive that or spend
$1,000 uh that being said uh because
it's a fairly simple Bill uh I'm open to
any questions thank you questions from
the
committee well that was easy okay thank
you representative Howard um thank you I
thought at least somebody asked a
question so let's go through here um
Hennessy thank you Mr chair good
afternoon everyone um I will leave it to
the committee whether you think this is
a good idea or not but I just want to
talk about a few um technical aspects of
the bill first of all our system is
capable of doing that so that's good
there's not a huge fiscal note attached
to this um as the representative said
these are um already in the system
they're called no activity reports um
one thing I just do want to point out is
that the language in lines 14 through 15
is repeated language that's already
mentioned above so I would just say pick
or choose where you would want that
language but just say it once for
clarifi just to clarify for our office
also we would look for clarification
about the language on um expenditures so
on line eight it says candidates whose
expenditures do not exceed
$1,000 however on um the proceeding
lines they are receipts or expenditures
so if you're if you're L just looking
for expenditures I would say that it
might be a little confusing to those
candidates if they're supposed to file
receipts or expenditures or one of the
other or for both um I believe this
language was changed in HB 1091 that
came on of this committee last year that
it required receipts or
expenditures happy to take questions
okay questions from the
committee okay saying none thank you um
next up is uh
um hi thank you chairman and members of
the committee my name is Kaye of stadio
um but today I am going to be
representing Bob Perry a former member
of this committee and also he serves on
the board of open democracy which is a
nonprofit um so he says I am out of
state please do not construe my
non-appearance as a lack of interest in
the bill first and foremost my
experience while serving on the election
law committee years ago in informs me
that describing any bill as simple is
folly however I'm willing to say the
intent behind the bill is a simple one
it is to minimize the cynicism and
speculation over why such a high
percentage of candidates do not file
Financial reports as required by Statute
I'm aware that as of December 16th 2024
313 house candidates did not file
Financial reports for the 2024 election
norded six Senate candidates one
executive Council candidate
and it is reasonable to ask why while I
strongly disagree with the scotus
decision and citizens united I strongly
agree with its observation that
disclosure of political spending is
crucial to the public interest and in
the preservation of democracy indeed
courts since Buckley have upheld the
legality and importance of transparency
in the political realm the bill require
the placement of a check box to be added
to the existing reporting forms both
online and handwritten by which
candidates would affir affirm that their
spending was under the applicable
threshold during each reporting period
this affirmation would negate the
reasonable skepticism and concerns over
why such a high percentage of reports
are not being filed is it really because
they are exempt from filing or is it an
intentional disregard for the law an
attempt to hide or other various
considerations the Supreme Court gave us
a few wild checks on Wild West political
spending other than to allow spending to
be disclosed with the stakes as high as
they are the unprecedented amounts of
money flowing into presidential and even
local elections it becomes more
important each election cycle that
candidates explain why detailed reports
are not required of them a simple check
of the Box provides the public with the
degree of confidence the law is being
followed I urge OTP on HB 389 thank
you and are you taking questions could
you're speaking for Bob Perry or you not
sure if there are all right go for it I
love that let's go
all
right yeah yeah how's it how's it going
because it's cold here um questions from
the committee all right thank you um
next up or last up is Olivia zinc
representative gusovsky
gusovsky
goof yes uh can you grab the blue
sheet um good afternoon members of the
committee for the record Olivia zinc
executive director at open democracy and
I I'm a voter in Franklin um I think the
best way to describe how this bill works
is showand tell so when you file online
there's this box here that says no
activity report there's been no activity
on my campaigns if you file using the
paper form there is no said box so the
forms are different based on how you
file um and I just want to point that
out because I think it's important that
uh however we report it's consistent
based on which which way you report I
know that this problem will be solved
once everybody files online um which
hopefully will happen at some point
um the other thing um that I just want
to mention that hasn't been mentioned is
that I do think that this efficiency
will help the Attorney General when
they're investigating um who has filed
campaign Finance reports um right now we
don't know are the is it because
candidates didn't file or is it because
they didn't report um so I think that's
really important um to make sure that
there is great G transparency in our
campaign Finance I urge a to pass on
House Bill 389 um and the other thing
that I would just clarify is that if you
are amending the language um I think it
would be good to just instead of saying
there's been no activity since my
previous report it's I'm under the
threshold for reporting
um might might be clearer language too
thank you all right will you be taking
questions happy to okay are there
questions from the committee
seeing n thank you um I don't have
anyone else signed up to speak or other
pink cards is there anyone else present
excuse me who wishes to
speak I thought that was going to take a
lot longer I really this is my first big
scheduling mess up for the day I thought
that one was going to take a lot longer
um so we will close the public hearing
on um House Bill
589 um 3 389 excuse me uh there was one
person signed up who didn't speak Max mo
Baxley are you still here did they leave
okay they wrote something after it I
can't read it um and then 389 online had
20 in support one in opposition with
that I'll close the public
hearing um we'll
stand we'll hang out here because I'm
I'm going to look through these bills
again see if there's anything else we
can discuss but otherwise we don't have
another public hearing till 220 so give
me one minute to go over the bills in
our possession that we've had hearings
on
okay actually all right thank you so
since we do since I did mess up and we
do have 20 minutes to kill excuse
me canit since we do have 20 minutes
let's begin the discussion um on the
political advertising bills uh the the
sorry the um the ones on public property
so I'll open up the P I'll open up the
executive session for House
Bill let's start with uh House Bill
336 relative to the placement of
political advertisement on public
rideways is anybody everybody have a
bill get it up here on my
oh okay so we're on discussion on the
bill does anybody have does anybody want
to do the opening Salvo on this because
I know this one's going to this like
this I think this might might one of
those weird bills that may not be
partisan and may actually divide both
caucuses I don't know I could be
wrong does anybody have any thoughts
with okay representative Mirad thank you
for saving me from the awkward
silence can you turn on your microphone
though
um this is just kind of a grammatical
thing um but in the sentences that are
being added which are lines 4 through 7
you know the first Clause says well
unless permission is granted by this or
that the political subdivision or the
owner and just logically that means that
if either one grants permission that's
sufficient and then the next sentence
says no advertising shall be placed
without the owner's consent
and and that means that the first
sentence should probably say and or or
or just be grammatically clarified so
that you know first you need the
political subdivision approval or maybe
you don't need that at all I don't know
and then second you need the owner's
consent regardless so that or is just a
misplaced conjunction I would say I I I
would not to be picky no I think it's
actually Fair um I think you can strike
that granted by the political
subdivision because the land is when
you're talking about a public right away
over private land the land is still
owned by the private individual the
public just has a right to pass over it
um so I don't think you would actually I
personally wouldn't believe that you
would need the political
subdivisions so long as you're not
obstructing the right of way right so
long as you're not blocking it or
blocking a sight line I I don't think
you would actually need it nor do I
think it would be appropriate and I
definitely agree that it's confusing and
you definitely shouldn't have the
situation where the political
subdivision is somehow saying yes you
can put signs on this right of way and
the property owner is like no you can't
it's my land so I I tend to agree I
think you could just strike
that I I think you can just strike that
um by the political subdivision and just
kind of as a history of this bill the
sponsors did approach me I am a
co-sponsor but they they approached me
with the concept and I think originally
they were trying to do it to where you
could place political signs on all
public property and I said I'm not into
the free-for-all um and I think this is
kind of what they came
to as an attempt to meet in the middle
so for what whatever that's worth but I
think that's I I agree with that I
definitely don't think that the granted
by the pocal subdivision is relevant
representative Newsome with that change
that you just mentioned isn't that what
the status quo Bill existing already is
yeah I think and that's where I was
headed next with that because they're
not that's not what
their what they were originally trying
to do CU so our laws about putting signs
on public property are contradictory um
there's one section that says you can't
do it and then there's a section about
going around and picking up signs set it
on public property and who can do it so
it's like you have a section that says
you can't put the signs up at all and
then you have a section that says hey
but here's who can pick up the signs um
that shouldn't beyond the proper so they
that that you you rais that's where I
was trying to go with is they were
trying to get to the underly question
of should you be able to put signs on
public property to what extent and how
do you regulate it and it kind of got I
think muddled in the OS back and forth
um and we have two bills about this
subject obviously which is why I put
them together and why we got 20 minutes
we can hash it out now about what we
think representative C I was just
wondering if it'd be nitpicking to worry
about uh whether the town owns the the
street or whether it happens to be just
a RightWay over private
property my my house the town owns the
street so I actually have to mow grass
on the town's property send that town up
there to that um yeah this is not this
is one of those things where it's I
don't even know how you'd have to like
write for every possible scenario
represent
qua yes thank you Mr chairman I had the
same reading of that sentence that
representative mad mentioned it does
appear to give a political
subdivision uh authority to Grant
permission to a piece of private
property that's under a public right of
way and it had the exact same concern I
think it could be addressed by removing
that first Clause unless permission is
granted by the political the sub
subdivision or just take strike that out
directly in which case it uh no
political advertising shall be placed on
or a fix to any public
see uh I'm trying to see how I'm trying
to edit in my head as we're talking but
basically what I'm trying to get across
is that public property is owned by the
political subdivision
maybe
right maybe could be State fed can okay
no political advertising shall be placed
on or a fixed to any public property
owned by a political
subdivision except uh by permission of
the property owner that doesn't address
yeah I think it's even more about so the
I I I think the question at hand the or
doesn't belong there basically oh yeah
the language clunky there's no there's
no yeah there's no debating that the
language is clunky
um the question I hand the reason these
two bills are put together is I think we
should
address the the issue the the underlying
issue which is where can candidates put
signs on public property I I would
venture to say that everyone in this
room would agree that you can't put a
political sign on someone else's private
property without their permission I I
would venture to say everybody
everybody's on the same page there right
so the only so the question is is how do
we handle signs on public property and
that I do think there would be a
differing View and once again I don't
think it's partisan I think there' just
be differing views in all personally I
don't believe signs belong on public
property at all um I just I just don't
like them I don't I just I don't want to
see signs on public property at all I I
don't think they belong I think it's
lazy campaigning and it quite honestly
it just makes the state look trashy in
my opinion um if you want to put a
public if you want to put a sign up on
your own property that is your first
amendment right that I will defend to
the end um but you know it's where do
you draw the line right so if I go put a
sign out on the
highway right and it's on state ride of
way which is what on state proper let's
say the state owns the highway it's on
the state highway land and you know if
if if I could do that no one's going to
lose their mind if I go and I litter the
the front lawn of town hall with Barry
and the chicken sign um people are going
to be mad you know either way there's a
sign on public property right and I
guess my contention is is how do you how
do you adjudicate in
policy when one is okay and when one is
not okay so I kind of want to hear what
people's thoughts are like when is it
okay to do this I've already taken a
position of I don't I I'd rather just
not but when is it okay to do it in what
situation isn't okay and then the next
bill following up to this is what are
the abutter rights to that um you know
you could you can raise issue with
representative wier's Bill about the the
mechanics of it the underlying point is
is if you're in a butter and it's
technically state right away or land or
whatever you want to call it and
somebody puts a sign up there and it's
legal illegal whatever you want to call
it but it looks like it Shores like I
think there's a legitimate there's a
legitimate concern in there um but once
again you there's a there's a gray area
right if it's in the middle like he's
talking about if it's in the middle of
the triangle in the middle of the road
nobody cares if it's on your if it's
next to your land and implies that
you're doing it I can see why you'd be
upset so what are other people's
thoughts about the placement of these
political signs on public property
that's where I need to get to like where
are we at on that representative
toner I me my ultimate opinion would be
basically like the parallels with you
that um I don't want to see like if
there's like public common or Park I
don't want to see it littered with
political signs at any time um so I I
par the only question I would have is
that like the day of the elections like
in our town they have a designated area
at the high school where which is
technically public land that we could
place signs for that
day and I don't know how that would play
into this so there was conversation when
I was discussing this bill with the
sponsors I told I didn't have an
objection if a town passed an ordinance
saying you could put signs here or here
right um there were people that wanted
the default to be you can put signs
wherever you want in the town and the
town can ban where you can't put it and
I said no no no that's that's
free-for-all but I I I'd be okay with
that if the town passes dordan and says
you can put signs here during election
you know this is the election heing zone
for signs you can put it here during
this time like I'm totally cool with
that if there's a vote by a public body
and they can resend it I'm toally fine
but I don't want the I personally don't
want the default to be yes I think the
default should be no unless the town
says yes that's my personal opinion
representative
Grill yeah I think I'm I'm on the same
page maybe we could include language
that specifies the towns could vote for
special election earing sections of town
or whatever uh but I think this does a
good job addressing the gray area
between you know parts of town that
might look like public property might be
adjacent to a highway or a major road
and um I think i' also agree that we
should defer to the owner of the land
and I'd be I'd be fine with striking the
political subdivision part of that as
well um because I think that um makes it
again more deferential to the property
owner who has to look at the signs on
their property or near their property
every day and also prevents it from
being a free-for-all and everyone just
putting their signs up 93 North and um
mucking that up so I'm I think that
would be good and we could include the
um the language on Town specific
ordinances as well repres B I think I
saw your
hand thank you Mr chairman uh I'm going
to mark this on my calendar because I
totally totally agree with you on uh no
signs on public properties I just want
to mention that representative wood I
won't I won't be as
nice I I think this is way too
complicated I love the the signs I love
the fight it is the be one of the best
parts of running we have signs of public
property we have signs taking off public
property go to the town they made a they
passed they said could put them here we
could put them there all the towns are
so different there are areas I mean
people want to run they want to know
what they are there's there's a
contradiction I de what people all the
time not another sign everybody
recognizes our sign throughout the state
not another sign I said well want you
don't want to know who's running so it's
a contradiction here but it's a fun
contradiction to play with when you're
running you you're getting people upset
you're getting some people to like you
it's just part of the game we're going
to go over there now every public place
in my town I can't put a sign that's
ridiculous there's a lot of public
places that really don't even belong to
the town who the heck knows how it owns
you know we find when people upset we
move them it's that easy and some people
move them for us you know
that's I believe that's a
crime I believe that is a crime you can
doce jail time for that anyways rson har
bullia thank you very much real quick um
yeah I have to agree with uh The Chair
by and large I'm sorry but um when it
comes to primaries where you have about
15 candidates at the top of the ticket
guess who gets to remove all those signs
that that are left behind because it's
not usually the candidates that come by
and pick them up it's it's the people in
the town of that party have to go and do
all the clean up so yeah it's a big
trashy problem I I agree I'm I'm fine
with buttoning it up and I don't und
really understand I'll have to look up
but if you re if you somebody puts a
sign on your property that's not a crime
to remove it right no it's not if it's
on your property no it's not explicitly
allow it's explicitly allowed yeah um
other people I told you you guys this
wasn't going to be partisan I told you
this is this is one of those weird ones
that'll cut that'll cut different ways
um any other comments any yes Ron
Wilhelm I'm excited how how does the
North End of Manchester feel about uh SS
on public property well it's a great
question I appreciate you asking
chairman I think uh I'm I have not yet
pulled my constituents specifically on
this uh however listening to you talk
about that the solution of saying hey
let's let's defer to the municipalities
let's say if you pass in public session
uh you know some sort of a uh during
this time period or this particular
space signs can go up but otherwise
across the board they should be banned I
think that makes a ton of sense um and
would love to work with you on Crafting
and amendment I would love to do that a
a Barry Wilhelm election law Amendment
would blow a lot of Mines um I'll ask
follow up to that one if I if I may what
I think representative Mirad has some
ideas I hate the following words I I I
swore would never pass my lips this
session but I'm going to let them
interim
study oh God no no I I refuse I refuse I
refuse I refuse to look no one here no
one here wants to do
that um I think that's the next like
because there's it's right it's it's
complicated right because you have you
have
Municipal you have
County people forget County I represent
golf town I've got County property
County State and then feds which I I I I
think the I think it's banned on the
federal property but representative
toner thank you I just wanted to add
like because it was thrown around like
putting signs on like the interstate and
stuff like that that's it's
illegal um two uh
23673 236 that's an election law statue
yeah it's it's in cuz I worked in the do
yeah it's
Transportation um on federal highways
and federal like and that's federal land
and the turnpikes it's illegal to put
signs in any of the medians any of the
exit ramps going up um basically there's
fences a very large right of way in the
interstates systems and it's illegal to
do it so I'm gonna I'm going to blow
your mind here you ready uh political
advertising may be placed on state owns
rights of way as long as the
advertisement does not obstruct the safe
flow of traffic um and the advertising
is placed the consent of the Landor the
right of way so that's when they're
talking about I think highways they're
talking about you can do it it's it's
it's definitely conflict it conflicts I
I'm I'm with you like that's part of the
problem with this subject is it
literally conflicts with itself like the
election law conflicts with itself much
less with the transportation statute you
decided like it it
definitely it it's like our campaign
Finance laws which are say one thing and
we have a bill where it's like like one
one and immediately the other so um but
yes we'll have to that's you know once
again like what do it's not just state
right away on highways like that it's
state property in general like I'm
asking the question of what about state
property in general because the
municipalities right now don't have the
authority to control the state property
at all in any way right um so we have we
that's why I asked that question is is
you know state parks right state parks
represent qu
maybe modify that sentence uh no
political advertising shall be placed on
or a fix to any public property
including Highway rights of way unless
permission is granted by the owner of
that property
period because every piece of property
in our system has an owner whether it's
an individual or a governmental
organization or some other kind of
organization yeah so that I think would
clear up the confusion at least yeah
that would probably clear for the
confusion but it doesn't answer the
underlying problem of what should be
allowed well that would be in this case
that would be up to the owner of the
property whether it's the state or the
political subdivision as far as your
point about objecting to signs
personally I'm I'm with representative
wood I don't I don't object to the
display of colorful political colorful
display of political fervor but uh I
think that would make it clear and
unambiguous if we made a change as I
just suggested representative Mirad I
mean if chairman Barry's photo were on
the sign would you object to that
representative that's an entirely
separate issue I put a uh I put a
literal Chicken on my sign so as a part
of that by the way was to send the
message of what I thought about
political science that that presumes is
a machine robust enough to actually take
a picture of him it would break the
camera
immediately um other questions comments
other kind of thoughts about
signs and property
and you can't well that's the problem is
it's we're going to keep dealing with
this issue you got turn your microphone
yeah I'm sorry make it simple just up to
the people that own the property and let
us duke it out I mean come on we can do
this representative PR O'Brien thank you
uh I don't know this isn't really a
question it's a comment but as we're
we're we're in comment we're in EXA
session so you can comment as
um wer was representative w
wheer
werer was speaking I was thinking about
how I observe signs throughout the
community as I'm driving around you know
during election
time it makes a difference if it's on
public property or private property and
I can kind of tell I can tell the
difference but maybe I'm looking at it
you know from too too close maybe I'm
too close to the issue because I see it
and I say oh those are signs that are on
public property oh those are signs that
are in someone's actual yard and it
feels like that it's much more of an
investment that an individual is making
when they put it in their own yard it
means more to me um the other stuff just
looks like campaign staff putting signs
out this summer I saw one on Route 89
right on one of the exits and that was
just some campaign staffer who didn't
know yet that that was not not okay it
was gone soon after that but I felt like
I was a little too close to the issue to
really um understand it the way maybe
the General Public does and I if I was
like if I was wier's neighbor I don't
think I would assume that wer suddenly
started um endorsing someone that he
otherwise never would have I wouldn't
take that as an endorsement I would
understand that what what I was looking
at was on public property all right uh
we're at 220 so we're going to drop out
of executive session I'm going to leave
you with this um whenever I have a
question about how the general public
feels about political stuff I always ask
my wife um and the reason being is my
wife is very non-political um and the
only she she gets politics through
osmosis through me being on the phone
and and it being an important part of my
life um but I I I kind of use her as my
Lim test so there's this corner in go
town um coming out of Bedford uh 14
where 114 turns and every candidate just
throws signs in there and it looks like
confetti and she knows the names right
she knows because she's hearing me she
hears me says things about the
candidates um so she knows the names and
we were driving by um in September drove
through there and I I turn said hey we
we drove through that we were stopped at
the stoplight so we looked at the
confetti signs we stopped there we were
there for like a minute like 90 seconds
before we turned and we turned off and I
I drove forward and I said hey babe can
you tell me any name you just saw in any
of those signs she said other than the
Trump one no so that's you know that's
kind of how it it gets it gets to be
noise at a certain point is my point
anyways all right we're at 2:20 so we're
going to in the executive session uh if
we have time we'll come back to that
vigorating debate I did enjoy that um um
we're going to open up the uh public
hearing on cacr 3 relative to recall
elections providing that the general
court May authorize recall elections
representative Moffett do you have
written testimony is that what that
is yes all right can can you give that
to our our wonderful clerk thank you and
you are recognized representative
introduction thank you Mr chair I notice
your oper ation is very smooth and ahead
of schedule um I would point out that in
another committee room we also have two
clocks one is on the slow side one is on
the fast side which gives the chair some
discretion with time anyway um for the
record uh my name is representative Mike
Moffett uh representing marac District 4
beautiful towns of Lowden and
Canterbury so some students from my
original hometown of gron uh recently
did a state house visit just just last
week and I followed him around for a bit
and uh even when they visited the
legislative chamber adjacent to rep's
Hall uh and the district one senator
from Littleton gave a wonderful Civics
presentation to the youngsters from
gron and uh then he said are there any
questions and a young girl raised her
hand and asked if we don't like what
you're doing how do we fire you so the
senator was a bit taken aback by the
little girl's question and he explained
that when the next schedule election
comes up that the voters could make a
change if they wanted which brings us to
cacr three uh this is a measure we've
brought forth before that did not move
forward for whatever
reason uh but sometimes it takes us two
or even three tries to get something
moved forward that should move forward
like like this so please note line 12 uh
we're only talking about adding 22 words
to to our Constitution's Article Five
the general court article the
legislation legislator article quote and
to provide a recall procedure to permit
citizens to remove an elected official
before the end of a term of office
unquote that's all 22 words and it's
kind of enabling legislation if you will
it would empower the legislature to take
action in this area that that
constitutionally really can't do now so
this we don't have a prescriptive plan
here that would be down the road if this
ever passes and if the legislature and
its wisdom thinks that it should look at
a a a uh recall
procedure so when I brought this forward
the last time a rep State Rep approached
me in the lobby and said to me you know
we have two-year terms here I said oh
thank you and another rep approached
me another rep approached me and said
you know all elected officials in New
Hampshire serve two-year terms to which
I responded something to to the effect
well I'll be down uh I know I know that
I'm the guy who puts a lot of civics
measures in into play and into law so I
should probably point out which I just
did that uh Civics is something that I
taught take seriously and I'm very proud
of the stuff that I've gotten through
and I'm still trying to get
through uh so I get it our we have
two-year terms um but this really isn't
about
us it's really about Municipal and
County
officials uh back back momentarily to
legislators uh who as you probably have
heard serve twoyear terms um I'll point
out that a State Rep from our Gateway
city was elected last term despite some
serious legal problems some of you will
recall uh in fact when it came time for
our organization day um this rep was was
incarcerated at the
time uh the person was in the big house
not the state house and with our house
party breakdown something like 199 to
199 something like that there was acute
interest in in h the status of this rep
who was
incarcerated so that the point I'm
making is that even though this really
isn't particularly about two-year
positions it could be U it could be and
so if my if my representative was
incarcerated and it happens countless
examples all over the country not so
much in New Hampshire but I might be
like the little girl from gron and say
what do we do with my my rep in jail but
again this is mostly about three and
four year term so many elected Municipal
board members serve three-year terms as
you know select boards school boards on
and on three-year terms you you all are
the experts on that so uh we even have
some County positions now that are
four-year terms and so that's the nub of
this thing what this is to empower the
people what if a municipality a county a
town a city whatever uh has some Bad
actors what what if they get a skunk as
a school board member or or a select
board member or a county official
someone who lied like crazy to get
elected we've seen it we've all seen it
and then they do a 180 once they get
elected and they they go against what
they said they do or promised they do or
who they were and then the voters the
citizens are stuck with this person for
years two years three years even four
years uh so what what can we do what can
we do with these people well can you say
paid administrative leave that's happens
all too often so this is really about
empowering citizens and giving them a
away to fire if you will someone who
needs
firing someone who saw I submitted the
cacr said to me uh you know good luck
with that you think politicians will
ever give people the means to fire them
and I hate being called a politician I
don't think I'm a politician politician
some big money dude uh I I correct them
I say we're citizen legislate
legislators I'm I'm not a politician I'm
a citizen
legislator and I want to think that all
of all the legislatures in America the
truly the world famous 424 member New
Hampshire General Court where we earn
100 bucks a year is the the noblest
least corrupt body in America I believe
that so I'm not sure why these 22 words
haven't been added yet to our
constitution maybe this time
around so when the gron kids are walking
out of the legis relative chamber
adjacent to rep's Hall okay it's the
senate for you watching at home I'm
talking about the Senate um you can't
use profanity in here I'm sorry sir okay
uh I I hear Mr
chair um so I saw the little girl as
they left that other chamber and I went
up to her and I said uh to the little
girl I said uh that was a great question
I'm glad you asked it I'm not sure if
the senator liked the question but I did
and I just want you to know that we
working on
it um so a cacr is a heavy LIF it has to
get through this uh esteemed committee
then then the full house if it gets
it'll go to the house anyway it has to
be voted on it's the cacr it needs 60%
and then it needs
67% approval in a Statewide ballot is is
as you know this committee knows that
better than anybody we just had a cacr
in the ballot November it got 66 six
plus perc it came just short of the 67%
that was on the judicial retirement age
but you know what uh I believe if our
fellow Granite Staters get a chance to
vote on this
cacr I think it would pass easily and
that's saying quite a lot 67% is a high
bar I truly believe if the voters if the
people had a chance to win and and uh
improve the constitution in this manner
uh 70 80% I believe that I think the
people want this our people our the
people we represent so I hope this
committee and its Collective bipartisan
wisdom this by by the way is a bipart is
said bipartisan support it's not a
partisan Bill uh I hope you'll give CAC
cacr 3 a chance and uh and eventually
give the people a chance and I'm happy
to try to answer any questions if there
are any questions from the committee
representative wood thank you Mr
chairman are you aware there's a way
there is a way now to remove an elected
official am I aware that there is a way
now to remove an elected official I know
there are some processes in place in
certain uh uh you're talking about on
the municipal level correct correct
anybody elected right I believe it's
anybody that's elected there are actions
that can be taken um so why would we
need another
action well uh represent you you go
ahead and describe the action now if
somebody in Pittsfield was a s or let's
say any Town someone from any town was a
uh a corrupt uh board member who uh
needed to be removed uh tell us that
process if you he can't he can't he
can't do that he can't it's a it's a
one-way Street okay yeah uh to answer
your question yes there are ways to do
that now I think they're cumbersome I
think that they're not easy I think this
would this would enable the legislature
to put the imprimer of the general court
on a process yet to be determined that
would apply not only to uh Municipal
officials but also County and state
officials does that help a little bit
thank you yes repres thank you for your
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for taking my
question uh what about appointed
officials such as on local level uh my
town clerk happens to be appointed or
the deputy clerk not the in the the
actual town clerk is is elected but also
like on the state level the various
appointed uh department heads of all the
uh various State
departments that is a great question and
you all heard the question what about
appointed officials so that's the beauty
of this proposal uh representative is
that if this enabling language get into
the Constitution then uh the legislature
then uh folks uh reps or people in this
committee could come up with some sort
of language to uh uh enable uh
municipalities to do something about a
appointed official uh that may or may
not be
uh uh that we may or may not be able to
do anything about now so uh great
question and that's another reason I
think why this should be good to move
forward so that uh such actions could be
uh put into law to address
that further questions from the
committee
um y represent your head thank you thank
you represent would you if this were put
into operation would you have any
concern about extremist groups extremist
groups on the left and the right very
well-funded extremist groups um mounting
recall campaigns every time someone was
elected um where they disagreed with the
outcome of the election so that
Governors for instance would just
constantly and routinely face recall
campaigns in their first months in
office
thank you for the question
representative that's a a great question
honestly and my answer to that is uh not
that you're trying to scare anybody with
that but I I think that notion is the
type of notion that would spook people
and say well you know extremists could
come in and and and so we to avoid that
scenario we should uh not do this um I
will say that in our federal system it's
always useful to see what other states
are doing in many other states H you
know has this been a problem in other
states um
California uh not that I'm saying they
should be a model but California has a
recall provision uh they recently just
two years ago recall their governor how
did that happen they had uh tens or
hundreds of thousands of people sign on
to do that I don't think they were
extremist uh in fact in
2003 uh California uh did recall
Governor Gray Davis um because he lied
and he uh did this and did that and he
was not who he promised he'd be they had
a recall election and arold
Schwarzenegger or whatever his name was
became Governor so my my answer is that
uh is a good question and I trust the
American people in our processes and if
some you know small minority of
extremists wanted to uh do what you
describe I think the uh the better
angels that I think populate all of our
communities would
Prevail hopefully that answers your
question
somewhat
representative gusovsky
do we have that big of a problem in the
state where we need this change to the
Constitution um you know just a little
antidote in Northwood we have removed
one person from the school board and a
planning board member the town wanted to
remove that person we had a town meeting
and as a Selectmen I'm on the board we
chose not to remove that person so there
are processes in place and I'm just
amendment just for the sake of making it
do we actually have a problem that you
feel we need this amendment now thank
you for the question representative and
the the representative from Pittsfield
uh already made the great point that
there are processes in place as you
described in in Northwood to do this and
as I said earlier uh I really see a need
to uh empower the legislature to broaden
the the power of the people to take to
do more than uh take on what what
malfant they may see locally uh is
another example there may be some
localities where there's a whole cabal
of of of people who are not doing the
right thing so if this legislature
someday uh puts something into law that
would enable people locally to petition
or or have other means of redress to
address Mal fence when it occurs and it
does occur we can all think of examples
so yes I I I hear you you make a great
Point as the representative from
Pittsfield did but I think our existing
processes could be better and broadened
to include uh the the rare occasions
where there might be some County or
state officials um I I don't see this as
a threat to most two-year terms as I've
already mentioned but that can happen uh
I gave an example already of of one uh
State Rep who had they not resigned uh I
think the people would have wanted to
have the CH the chance to uh replace
that person and uh without um enabling
legislation that would enable you all to
come up with some ideas um then uh that
will still be out there and some if if
we don't do it now someday
somehow I believe that
we'll broaden our recall
procedures further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you Mr chair I don't think I have anyone
else signed up to speak for cacr 3 do I
me uh online there were nine in Support
and then on the blue sheet there
was two people signed up who didn't
speak both against uh with that we'll
close the public hearing on cacr 3 and
we'll wait two minutes to do cacr 4 look
schedule
e
all right it's 2:40 representative or
you want to grab a seat here our last
bill of the day we're on
schedule keep saying that because I'm so
happy about it uh going to open up the
house p uh public hearing on
ccr4 relative to voting eligibility
providing that only legal residents who
are at least 18 years of age or older
who reside in the place they claim as a
domicile should be eligible voters
representative oy is recognized for the
purpose of introduction represent
welcome to election law for the record
my name is Jordan oler Hillsboro 13
that's the town of Hudson uh in reading
the uh New Hampshire Constitution you
notice that any um inhabitant of a
community is entitled to vote just an
inhabitant doesn't have to live here
doesn't have to reside here just has to
declare a community in the town as his
inhabitants and he can vote we've run
into several issues of this today or
yesterday actually you look listen to
the news there were a couple of people
from uh
Massachusetts who were charged with the
crime of voting in Ashland repeatedly in
town elections and in state elections
and in federal elections now they may
have violated federal
law they may not have violated state law
because the Constitution says you only
have to be an inhabitant and they were
declaring
inhabitants in one town where they
actually spent Mo the majority of their
time someplace else we have a lot of
people who are as you know snowbirds
good time of year for
snowbirds uh except there's more snow in
Florida than there is in Southern New
Hampshire right
now but the idea is to codify our
constitution to say exactly what it
meant when it was first put into
existence that is that if you're going
to be a resident you need to be a legal
resident you need to be 18 years of old
a of age you need to be a qualified
voter you need to be a citizen of the
United States and you need to actually
reside where you say you do put that in
the Constitution it just tightens up the
entire legal
process very short very sweet right to
the point just a couple of
lines and I'll be happy to answer any
questions other questions from the
committee on representative wood thank
you Mr chairman I was looking through
the the bill here and I noticed you took
out inhabitant twice and further down
the every inhabitant of the state I'm
sorry on page two line
17 every inhabitant of the state having
the proper qualifications did you mean
to keep it there and
that more eyes that see it more eyes
catch things thank you sir no that
should be corrected
committee oh wow okay all right
thank you representative or I thought
read more question on that I guess not
all right um next up is Liz tantarelli
from the League of Women Voters m t I
don't think we've seen you yet this year
so welcome to election
law if we have my apologies I just don't
remember it but I I don't believe we've
we I don't I don't remember either but
thank thank you representative Barry
things things are kind of confusing this
year um I I just realized I signed in
the wrong blue sheet so anyway here I am
I've got you've got my card so thank you
for this opportunity to speak I'm Liz
tentarelli I live in Manchester I'm
president of the League of Women Voters
uh we're a nonpartisan organization and
one of our U self-imposed obligations is
that when a a constitutional amendment
comes up we try to explain it to voters
and unfortunately the way our ballots
are set up nobody quite knows what the
change is and it's it's a real challenge
for voters to understand what they're
voting
for in this case I'm opposing the bill
itself because of the term legal
resident because I think most people
don't know what that
means for instance is a homeless person
a legal resident we know that they are
allowed to vote and they can use their
social service agency as an address to
vote we know that somebody who's incar
incarcerated in a House of
Corrections is allowed to
vote uh either while a waiting trial or
while serving a misdemeanor sentence are
they a legal resident it's it's just a
weird phrase what about the young person
who is a roommate and has no uh name on
a lease somebody else has the lease he's
a roommate uh you know my grandson was
in that position for a couple of
years is he a a legal resident so I
think when you start putting in words
that the average voter is going to
scratch one's head about and and just
not know what it means that that doesn't
help
anything uh this this amendment uh I'm
sorry the the the wording that already
exists clearly says you need to be you
you need to be domiciled you you're
there you have to be a citizen you have
to be 18 you know we we we know this
already and so I think all this does is
create
confusion and I think I don't
particularly want to take questions on
this but thank you for the opportunity
to speak you are the first one this year
not to take question and I love that I
love that there's
take better it's awesome all right next
Kay members of the committee um my name
is Kaye of stadio I'm a Durham voter and
public policy fellow with open democ Y
and again I am testifying on behalf of
Bob Perry a former member of this
committee and a board member on open
democracy so he says I write an
opposition to cacr 4 the cacr makes
major changes of consequence for voting
under the New Hampshire Constitution as
it currently exists the proposed
amendment removes references to
inhabitants dating back to the original
language in
1784 defining inhabitant as a person who
has a domicile I suggest the founders
recognize the mobile nature of settlers
so chose not to confine them to a
standard of permanency by way of
residency such that any definition of
residency could account for the
movements of the early settlers in
search of safety home or job any more
than the movements of modern persons
there is no definition of quote legal
resident or its derivatives in the
amendment therefore the intent of the
amendment would be subject to a
definition determined by the legislature
after the amendment were to become law
thus adding ambiguity potential surprise
or remorse there is a definition of
Resident and its derivatives in the
motor vehicle statute at RSA 21 but such
statute does and should not bear a
connection between the privilege of
driving a motor vehicle and the
fundamental right to vote in the state
at part 1 article 11 of the New
Hampshire
Constitution existing state statutes of
longstanding under RSA 654 set out
requirements for voting that a person
must be a citizen of the US and the
requisite fors for voting amply set out
those requirements with penalties for
wrongful voting included in the forums
the language quote and actually reside
in the place they claim is domicile is
problematic the word reside a derivative
of the word resident conflicts with the
rights of students for example who may
claim their place of Higher Learning as
their domicile under RSA 6541 for
purposes of voting the amendment would
also be problematic to overseas vot
voters under RSA
6543 uniformed overseas citizens
absentee Voting Act who may claim a US
domicile even while temporarily
stationed overseas whether short or long
term who obviously do not actually
reside in the place they claim as
domicile adoption of this amendment
therefore would require the repeal of
multiple statutes to include RSA 6
6541 voter office holder RSA 6542
temporary absence or presence RSA 654 2A
voters confined in Penal institutions
RSA 6543 uniformed and overseas citizens
absentee Voting Act RSA 6547 voter
registration voter registration form and
a potential for other appeals not
noticed here I urge
itl and me speaking as myself I also
just wanted to add that as I mentioned
previously I am a Durham voter and
student at UNH although I am from
Massachusetts I do actually reside in
the place I claim as domicile for 10 out
of the 12 months of the year probably
more um I spend way more of my time in
New Hampshire and its laws affect me way
more than Massachusetts do and it makes
more sense for me to vote there I also
plan to move here postgraduation and
countless others like me are in the same
situation so I am worried that the
language actually leaves too much room
room for
interpretation thank
you will you be taking questions uh sure
all right are other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you last up
we have Olivia zinc with open
democracy um
representative
sheet um for the good afternoon I think
I'm standing between you and leaving so
I'll be quick it's it's a dangerous
place the only other worth place to be
is
that's that's that's like whoa um I'm
Olivia zinc executive director of open
democracy and I live in Franklin New
Hampshire um and I'm Po and here
opposing this bill currently um the
Constitution um guarantees the freedom
of all inhabitants that are 18 years
older and citizens um the ability to
vote in New Hampshire and I think it's
important that we make sure that we're
not um unintentionally harming any voter
um as mentioned before it could be
somebody home Hess it could be somebody
that's recently divorced and staying on
a friend's couch um there are many
different uh way reasons where somebody
may not
um uh have a legal
resident uh I was just wondering what is
a legal resident in New Hampshire so I
looked elderly voters are residents of
nursing homes under RSA
151 and we know that elderly voters can
vote from their nursing home or from
their previous home um we allow them
that uh Choice um in our election laws
so we'd have to change those statutes if
we make them a legal resident and and
and uh no longer elderly voters would
have that choice um and then what is
what is uh legal residents when you are
purchasing um a house or leasing a
leasing an apartment those are different
rsas around residency and there's the
motor vehicle residency statute there is
placing dependent children in publicly
funded schools statute and then there is
a whole host of statutes about what is
your residency under Health and Human
Services I've cited all of these
different statutes of what is residency
because I think it's important for us to
know which one of these residency
standards would be what we would be
defining to vote for folks to vote under
this this proposed amendment I urge the
committee uh to to support
um everybody's freedom to vote and and
vote itl on this Constitutional
Amendment with that thank you and I
won't take questions oh yes all right
double up no questions today all right
uh we have no one else uh no other pink
cards in my possession um uh there was
one person on the blue sheet signed up
against who did not speak online there
was 110 in support and 95 opposed which
is why I thought this one would go a lot
longer um so um my apologies I probably
would have put in two more bills if I
knew we were going to fly through this
this one um we're done for the day close
to public cacr 4 um quick some quick
announcements uh yes we are meeting next
Tuesday um yes uh every Bill we heard
today so the Cadence will be the bills
we hear on Tuesday will be by default
noticed um for the next Tuesday so that
that'll be kind of the Cadence so if
there's a bill that needs work right you
need to let me know um it's not a big
deal I just need to know but that's
going to be the Cadence I'm going to
take the 11 bills that we heard today
and are going to be noticed for exec at
the end of day at the end of the day for
next week um and I know representative
Mirad is trying so hard not to hear my
voice anymore but I do need to speak
with you and the vice chairman about
scheduling for Bill hearings next week
I'd like your consultation on it um so
with that I will see you guys next
Tuesday at 10: a.m. for hearings and
executive sessions so uh Deputy ranking
member and vice chairman please make
sure your substitutes are in place and
yes we will meet in 308 represent Mirad
thank you guys see you next